so Mark Zuckerberg has launched his app
threads they call it the Twitter killer
and I signed up to check it out and it
is awful I'm not just trying to play
some stupid tribal games the the main
feed on threads is a bunch of random
people I don't follow so I sign up for
this new Twitter killer and I'm like all
right let's check this out and I go to
my home page and there's like some dude
named Roderick talking about how him and
Jay boys was going down to the the
quartz hall for for a new drink and I'm
like
I I have no idea what this guy's talking
about I don't want to follow him and you
can't you have to block them and so
people are literally like well I guess
what you do is if you see a post you
don't like block the person so you never
see it again like the whole thing is
this I'm getting a bunch of weird Brands
and garbage I don't care about but
anyway
it sucks but we'll talk more about it
and where it's at because sure enough
there is room to improve and some people
are excited there's an alternative to
Twitter because some people are still
banned on Twitter but here's where it
gets interesting Twitter is threatening
to sue meta for stealing Trade Secrets
why according to Twitter Mark Zuckerberg
hired Twitter employees who had access
to proprietary information from Twitter
which they used to make the new app very
interesting so we'll see right now a
seasoned assist letter was sent out Elon
Musk called it cheating we'll talk a bit
about that and then as it pertains to
good old Joe Biden oh boy
politics you gotta love it apparently
the cocaine they found was actually near
The Situation Room yeah not not just the
West Wing Dan bongino mentioned that
this has got to be someone in the family
someone who can bypass security and
that's exactly what we're saying but hey
he would know better than we would so uh
I think everybody kind of knows where
that stuff came from so we'll talk about
that I've also got a bunch more uh uh
little stories here we gotta uh we do
another big one with Joe Biden they're
effectively trying to overturn the First
Amendment you know I try I want to avoid
being hyperbolic but the filing from the
bite Administration seeks to grant them
the authority to have private
organizations censor the political
speech of people they don't like and it
is an unprecedented move it's insane
effectively the bite Administration is
filing an appeal for the right to bypass
the First Amendment shockingly insane so
we'll talk about that before we do my
friends head over to castbrew.com and
join the cast Brew Coffee Club if you
like really good coffee and you want the
best you're going to buy from castbrew
and you'll also be supporting the work
we do because this is our company we're
sponsoring ourselves you can join the
cast Brew Coffee Club well you get you
will get three bags of coffee every
month we've got rise with Roberto Jr a
light roast we've got Appalachian nights
at dark roast I got to be honest I think
Appalachian nights is the best coffee
I've ever had you know I'm the one who
formulated it so surprise surprise I
made what I liked they come in whole
bean or ground
and again casper.com we're currently
working on setting up a coffee shop we
may even actually launch a second
location before we even get started just
so we can speed things up also don't
forget to go to timcast.com click join
us become a member because we're gonna
have a members only uncensored show 10
p.m tonight where you as a member
actually can submit questions and
perhaps even call in and talk to us and
our guests so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Lauren Chen thank you for having
me super stoked to be here absolutely
who are you so my name is Lauren Chen I
am a Blaze TV host as well as a TP USA
contributor and I also make videos on
YouTube so I have my own channel Lauren
Chen and another Channel mediaholic
where we talk about pop culture
Entertainment movie reviews and then my
main channel is more current events
social and political issues and I
basically am everywhere on social media
and I I don't know I feel like I'm often
very angry on social media there's a lot
of things to talk about politically in
terms of entertainment that are not
going well so I guess I'm I'm an angry
person online this is what we do we
complain about things on the internet
yeah but then it's like we're making
content that's content people are
watching it they like absolutely well
thanks for hanging out should be fun we
got Phil Labonte he's here how you doing
I am philibonti lead singer of All That
Remains anti-communist encounter
revolutionary good to see you guys bye
everybody Ian Crossland ready to rock
and roll let's move it alrighty and as
you say I'm surge.com ready when you are
Tim check out this story from ABC News
Twitter sends meta cease and desist
letter over new threads app say sources
now this is confirmed Elon Musk has even
uh called it out he said competition is
fine cheating is not Twitter Daily News
tweet uh tweeting Twitter is threatening
to sue meta over systematic willful and
unlawful misappropriation of Twitter's
Trade Secrets and IP as well as scraping
of Twitter's data in a cease and desist
letter sent yesterday to Zuckerberg by
elon's lawyer Alex Spiro I have to
wonder recently we heard that Twitter
was limiting how much how many tweets
you could see and they said it's because
people were stealing data I wonder if
it's because Elon found out meta was
actually scraping data to use for their
new app I mean Mark Zuckerberg doing
something untoward in regard to like
intellectual property that doesn't sound
right guys Mark Zuckerberg wouldn't do
that it's not like he has a history of
that we put the very creation of
Facebook to be fair his his history of
trying to create rival alternative
social media platforms has not fared too
well for him that's true I'm gonna try
they tried to do a signal type thing
didn't work out they tried to do a
Snapchat type thing didn't work out I am
pretty sure threads will not work out
look man it might but it is a really bad
platform there are people on the left
who are tribally just saying woo it's so
much better and I'm just like dude
you log into the app let me let me I'm
gonna log in right now I'm gonna I'm
gonna pull it up and I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna like so first of all it's
recommending AOC to me like crazy I do
not follow AOC on this and uh let's
let's see what what it wants me to so
there are people I follow
and uh I do see their posts okay what's
this puberty what is what pubity I've
seen puppet the largest and most
populated city on earth Tokyo Japan
that's a cool picture I don't care
that's I I followed them on Instagram
where I at least get recommended them a
lot I think they're just like a general
interest kind of yeah now this or
something Paris Hilton oh that's great
uh let's see complex magazine don't know
what that is Ellen DeGeneres not
interested I don't know who that person
is I don't know who that person is like
these are these are people posting
things about like their day that have
nothing like I'm getting recommended the
dude who made threads I don't care about
this look my whole feed look at this
like none of it is people I follow so
micro game tweets the threads from
Microsoft yo
I don't want to look at a feat of random
advertisements that's what it is it's
all ads it's the algorithm saying here's
something you might like here's
something I don't like it I don't like
it what am I supposed to do you can't
turn it off is when when you sign up for
Threads does it connect to your Facebook
account you can have it connect to your
your Instagram so how do you download it
anyway I think you go to well it's in
the play store but I had to go to
threads.net to download it is it called
threads it's like threads comma a meta
app or something like this it's
recommending me Ted Cruz okay I don't
follow Ted Cruz or AOC at least it's not
just AOC Jubilee media what is this one
the Blaze TV I don't follow the blaze
seriously they get suspended all the
time so you know it is weird that it's
recommending The Blaze to me I don't I
don't I look that's not the least of it
it's it's very limited in what's what's
available to do on the platform but
here's here there's the one thing I said
on threads as to why it's not that good
look I don't care what my favorite
nature photographer has to say
at all
I I don't follow people on Instagram I
follow people who play poker I follow
people who skateboard who who uh scoot
who BMX uh some nature like a couple
like travel people and some Parkour
people I'm not an Instagram for a news
feed so when I start threads and it's
like here are the people you follow it's
like oh sure like I follow prageru for
and a few people for some of their
political stuff but it's mostly not
here's ultimately what I think and the
reason why I bring up the algorithmic
feed
I think what the powers that be feared
the most in terms of social media was
curated feeds which created tribes and
hives
people go on Twitter they follow only
the opinions they like and they create
these bubbles where they separate
themselves from everybody else I think
what Instagram wants to do what Mark
Zuckerberg wants to do
uh YouTube does the same thing they want
to eliminate the ability for you to
create a curated feed this has been sure
on YouTube Forever subscriptions on
YouTube are completely meaningless and
have been for 10 years everybody knows
that when you say homepage yeah when you
subscribe to a channel it doesn't matter
you're not going to get fed that content
it's going to be whatever's on the home
page so YouTube chooses if you're
actually there and gives this this
impression that your you know your
subscriber count matters but it really
doesn't really doesn't
Instagram meta they want to do the same
thing with Twitter
so that when you sign up for Threads
they are really hoping that it does shut
down Twitter and then this is what the
future will be you will be forced to
follow the likes of The Young Turks
you'll be forced to follow the likes of
AOC or Ted Cruz
perhaps they think it'll be a healing
thing to bring the sides together so
that everyone will have a shared
narrative but let's be real they've
already censored DC Drano if you try to
fight there was a post where they were
showing if you tried to follow him it
warns you that he's fake news we know
exactly where it's going you're going to
follow conservative and libertarian
dispected liberals those are going to
get de-ranked without you knowing
they're going to prop up people like AOC
and neocons you know acceptable
Republican personalities Ted Cruz for
instance and they're going to try to
excise the likes of you know anyone
outside the political machine big
problem for me with centralized media in
general is part of why I don't like this
idea that elon's been pushing to create
an app for everything a One-Stop app the
X app because if Elon doesn't like you
Alex Jones he can just ban you from
everything then if you're putting
everything through a central server same
with metamam too much power the DC Drano
gotta already put on a list or was on a
list I don't like it man I don't like it
well they can't force people to get out
of their silos you got to let them do it
on their own you gotta Inspire them to
do it the only in interest I would have
an alternative to Twitter is even more
free speech because like you said Elon
he's not totally he has this personal
Vendetta against Alex Jones I actually
think that it's he doesn't want to get
banned from the App Store but it's more
unpopular to say that than to say oh I
just have a very strong opinion about
his uh treatment of the Sandy Hook
people but in any case you're not going
to get more free speech from anything
Mark Zuckerberg owns than something that
Elon Musk owns so in my opinion why I
mean I can understand what if you're a
leftist and you want more content
moderation you'd rather have a threads
conversation than a Twitter conversation
because the moderation is going to be
more what you're looking for but I mean
for people like DC Drano it doesn't it
it's it's never going to be as free as
Twitter is you know what'll make the
magic if threads and Twitter come
together and cooperate and you can
threads has stated they will soon be on
the Theta verse so this is actually
really interesting I think the fediverse
is a very very important move for social
media that can actually fix a lot of the
problems for those aren't familiar it's
effectively
the internet of social media so imagine
this imagine early early internet to go
to a website you're like you log into
AOL and then AOL shows you a list of
things you can click but there are
websites of course
today you have Twitter you have Facebook
you have YouTube you can go on that
platform and see people with the
fediverse all of these different apps
will interlock with each other so you
can go onto threads and see someone's
tweet you could see someone's blue sky
post someone's masted on post someone's
Gap post so that that's actually a very
very good thing however if that is the
case there's no reason to use threads
because it's a Zuckerberg platform you
might as well just use any of the other
fataverse apps but that that stops
censorship if if we can get a Twitter
like system if we can get Federated
networks what happens is you might sign
up for Threads because it's easy
you can see posts from Phil on Twitter
and then you can you know threads might
be like we're blocking Twitter from from
our Network because we don't like him
but Phil can then sign up for any other
fediverse app or connect it that way and
Syndicate so ultimately you can't be
censored
in fact you can even create your own
website with your own protocol where you
can never be banned because your
username would be like Ian Ian
crossland.net or whatever so then people
would just follow you from your website
so it's kind of like RSS feeds turning
Twitter into a network of servers
instead of one centralized platform so
that's good
but yeah there's actually these things
called ens domains ens it's ethereum
Network server names I believe it's they
think it might be like your ID on the uh
web 3.0 and you go to like ens dot
domains
um but you buy it with crypto and it's
like you can use your name.eath eth
which is the ethereum thing you use pay
ethereum for it that might be one way to
have like a a presence that can that can
bounce around from Network to network or
or you control your own because it'll be
like a wallet where you have your money
and your ID all together where you can
log into all these different sites and
imagine if nobody could ban you because
nobody owns your server all they can do
is block you that's the way it should be
the problem now is with threads or
Twitter or any other platform there's
some dude who's like I'm just gonna ban
you you can't do that in the real world
you can't get banned from like walking
down the street and saying your opinions
you know to a certain or the phone
company it Can't Ban you right to a
certain degree you can of course because
people lie cheat and steal all the time
and you know corrupt government
officials will try and play dirty games
the point is we are protected in
expressing our opinions I hope that's
where this all goes and uh I don't know
what Jack Dorsey is working on but I
just want to give a shout out to Jack
Dorsey because he recently did a podcast
interview where he said that JFK was
assassinated by the CIA and he like got
very into it and he's like so you're
saying it's like he's like yes at that
point was when the American dream was
stripped away when our own government
met the CIA kill the sitting president I
was like wait what what why would you
act yeah wait didn't they basically
admit that
I don't know if they admit I know
Tucker's said it Ron Paul said it like
we're at the point where basically it is
a it is it is maybe I'm too far down the
conspiracy rabbit hole for too many
things where I'm just like yeah I
thought we were all on the same page
like yes I love the Kennedy conspiracy
assassination conspiracy because I there
are people who say it's multiple gunmen
you know and it's Lee Harvey Oswald it's
all pinned on this one guy but like The
Story of Lee Harvey Oswald's crazy first
he screamed out I'm a patsy as they were
carrying him away they found his gun in
the building that he was in like on
another floor so like if you're gonna he
gets killed yeah and then someone comes
up and kills him but like if you're
gonna commit that crime you wouldn't
like put your gun in a room and go
upstairs and have lunch afterwards who
in the right mind but I did not want to
ignite
that conversation just shouting out Jack
Dorsey because I saw that clip but the
point is you know he made Blue Sky I do
want to say one thing on the one last
thing before we move on
there's a there's a funny post I saw
where uh this Twitter user said it is
2023 and I'm joining Mastodon it is 2023
and I am joining Blue Sky it is 2023 and
I am joining threads and it's a picture
of Dr Manhattan from Watchmen like
sitting on Mars I just thought that was
really good I'm like you guys stop
trying it's not gonna work threads is
already censoring things yeah that's you
can't curate your feed
the point of Twitter is that it is where
we are angry with each other that's it
sorry have a nice well I mean because
Mastodon that was already the left-wing
alternatively bound to fail just because
it doesn't it's not an easy thing yeah I
did try to log on and create an account
just so I could kind of see what the
leftists were talking about it was not
very intuitive and I'm kind of a boomer
I'll admit but still it wasn't nearly as
easy as Twitter but I think even the
leftists who claim that they want all
the you know the quote right-wing
extremist banned they know that Twitter
is fun because of that conflict that but
they can't stay away so here's what I
think the right wants to debate the left
they want to have this big conversation
the left wants to ban everyone on the
right
the thing is Twitter is the water cooler
it is the Town Square so the left wants
the right band from it so they have a
monopoly on the narrative the right
wants to use the platform to engage in
debate it does not work for either if
the other leaves if these liberals and
leftists leave and go to Mastodon
they're no longer in Town Square they
have no narrative control there's no
point being there sure you've banned all
the conservatives but now you have no
influence right for conservatives if
there's no one to talk to but each other
it's boring there's no debate truth well
they want the conservatives right the
leftists want the conservatives on the
platform so they're able to feed the
conservatives what they want them to see
they don't want conservatives in their
own Echo chamber because then they're
going to be talking about the leftists
in a way that they don't like I want to
pull up this tweet from Alvin Elon Musk
responded to this tweet with an
exclamation point he said dear God what
the f
I give you now this image threads an
Instagram app I'll give you the short
version they're basically spying on you
in every way imaginable data safety
let's see data shared personal info
device or other IDs data collected
location personal info Financial info
health and fitness messages photos and
videos audio files and docs calendars
contacts app activity web browsing app
info and performance device or other IDs
now that's amazing can you say it's
encrypted can you say no to those
there's these carrot drop downs on the
right can you click those I mean this
isn't obviously interactable this is
basically saying what they're doing so
look at this like you have to opt in
they have your location they have your
name email user ID address phone number
political or religious beliefs sexual
orientation a lot of times you'll be
able to opt out yeah but they'll opt you
in if you don't know they take your
financial info your credit score you are
giving them is this for if this is
legitimate I just want to make sure like
someone someone posted this and assuming
this is real like you're giving your
credit score your health info and
fitness info so how much you weigh your
your blood levels advertisers must be so
aroused right now this is everything
they're giving your email Voice or sound
recordings files and documents quite
literally it can go into your calendar
events what is that all of your content
look at your all your videos on your
phone the contacts is crazy because if
some random person that never signed up
for social media is in my phone then now
Instagram has them and they'll start
marketing to them
well not just even more insidiously we
know the federal government has been
working with social media companies if
they can see who's following who like
who's not just following on social media
but actually who has who in their
phone's contacts that's really really
scary I always saw that someone at it's
a former CIA uh employee someone that
worked for CIA is now moved over to I
believe it was Facebook meta I'm looking
for the Tweet now but I actually had an
experience a couple weeks ago Alex Jones
was on the pbd podcast Patrick Beth
David and he asked some question on
there like if we install in Russia if
there's like a new leader is installed
and they're sympathetic to the West what
will happen well and nobody really had
an answer and I was going to text him
Alex and be like well I think that would
move us to his totalitarian you know
technocracy a little bit faster more
peaceful but also that and I just didn't
message him because I don't want the FBI
reading my what a I was
so angry at myself that I didn't be
brave like I just so the the guy that is
for the ca Aaron Berman former 17-year
CAA officer is now head of Elections
policy for Facebook and Instagram Berman
joined Facebook in 2019 and was
responsible for writing misinformation
policy and enforcing it for the 2020
election covid Brazilian elections Etc
he's joined by 15 other CIA FBI and DHS
working in trust and safety so so real
quick I did confirm these images it's in
the Play Store it is real can you drop
them down on the right one thing I want
to do real quick though is I want I I
went to the Twitter app on the Play
Store I do not see the same thing it
doesn't have anywhere
yeah it doesn't have this stuff do you
who's that guy that tweeted that because
I want to take a look and retweet that
this is so hard to navigate that's not
so when I go to Twitter I don't see it
let me try let me see what truth social
does data safety starts with you blah
blah blah see the details uh
so data collected from truth social your
personal info email addresses user ID
phone number messages other in-app
messages photos and videos contacts app
activity info performance and device IDs
that's actually all normal right the
reason why it says photos and videos and
this is true for meta is because you
post them so it needs access to those
you know it doesn't have anything else I
mean contacts are there because it'll
ask you in-app messages I don't care
about your email address well of course
you log in sign in with that so it
really it is true that uh uh threads by
Instagram is basically audio files like
it's taking everything yeah it's it's
probably it's the same thing that Tick
Tock does I wonder if Instagram does the
same thing people talked about the the
amounts of data that Tick Tock collects
sounds like thread does threads does the
same Instagram has basically the same
thing it does Instagram basically takes
everything as well yeah this is Facebook
this is what they do and like knowing
that man how can how can people it's
just such a convenient tool but it's so
Insidious that they're tracking
not your every move but all right
Twitter your psychology Twitter takes
um not nearly as much it doesn't access
your files and documents but it does
have quite a bit of information your web
browsing history Twitter takes uh
app functionality analytics advertising
and marketing your web browsing history
Twitter takes that too so it looks like
Twitter is very bad threads is
substantially worse but don't be
surprised when everyone's spying on you
and I'll just make sure it's clear that
I don't want to single out threads on
this one
they are spying on you to a greater
degree than the other ones but uh
they're all spying on you quite a bit
well I mean anyone if anyone who has an
Alexa or a Google home assistant or
whatever they're called that is
essentially a wiretap that you've
allowed into your home all these phones
are this phone is tracking me right now
because if you say uh let's what is the
thing voice activation Okay Google
it Buzz why I push the button oh okay
how can I help
if your phone TV or any other device has
voice activation that means it is
listening to every single word you say
very likely recording it and
transmitting it it has to record it the
way voice activation works is that it
records what you say sends it to a
company for analysis who then scan it
for Tech to convert it to text and sends
it back to the TV so if your TV
is voice activated many people have this
now
if you can just walk up and say
something like Okay Google or whatever
it ever every word out of your mouth
gets sent to this company for analysis
and it's just waiting to hear the
activation command
they save all that data of course they
keep it all what they say is don't worry
it's anonymized we don't actually know
who you are and I'm like yeah yeah you
know who you are because I'm talking
about who I am you're you can't really
have all of my personal conversations
and say it's anonymous because no it's
not that's not how conversations work
but uh our our TV actually has something
where we can turn off the the voice
activation function like uh through the
hardware like a lot of laptops have that
with uh webcams now but if you do that
there's a stupid little light that will
remain on and it's annoying because they
want you to have the thing open right
because they want to be listening to you
they also uh this Alvin guy also posted
this app privacy from Instagram and it
says the following data may be collected
and linked to your identity health and
fitness Financial info contact info user
content browsing history usage data
Diagnostics purchases locations contacts
search history identifiers sensitive
info and other data what does that mean
my favorite is credit score it said
credit score a credit score dude
Zuckerberg just wants to know everything
about you I think it's because that's
crazy I mean think about what that means
for advertisers if they're plugged into
your credit score they can actually bid
to advertise on people who have good
credit scores like if you're a credit
card or something like that that's scary
that's messy you know what I wonder if
like maybe the AI took over a long time
ago and it's just learning everything
possible about us it feels you don't
realize we're under its spell it feels
inevitable I don't know if I'm like if
I'm um broken and I'm just like giving
up or if it's actually inevitable if the
AI takeover not like electricity didn't
take us over we weren't taken over by it
we just all use it mostly so AI it might
be similar it might not take us so it
might just don't use it but uh what a
powerful tool especially when it can
talk to you and tell you things
what the AI the artificial intelligence
it's freaking weird man no ai ai really
scares me and it's a it's also kind of
ironic and people have been posting
about this like we assumed Ai and like
technology would come so we would be
relieved of menial jobs especially like
that's the dream if you're on the left
but instead it's like all the the
creatives that are being put out of work
almost first I mean obviously technology
has been for a long time phasing out
lower skilled jobs but it's like now
even the good jobs that people were
aspiring to those are the ones that are
also being wiped out by AI like you know
the the graphic designers the writers
yeah it's like it's less about can you
physically draw the picture now and and
more about can you conceive of the the
description verbally and then give the
computer an accurate like inter uh
intricate descriptive so when you come
up with it it's another type of art form
it'll produce another generation
actually so I I did a poll on that on my
Twitter and it was quite the Lively
debate whether AI art actually counts as
art is it art what is art I mean that's
philosophical about it I I think it is
art a lot of people will say it is not
art if it's created by AI incorrect it
is I I agree because I think there are
so many different tools that we have
evolved throughout time using to create
art why are we placing the limit on AI
yeah because if you use a laser to carve
something into wood yeah and I mean
people will say well oh it's it's just a
an amalgamation of previous art well
isn't that any art anyway we are the
product creation is usually the product
of you know I guess absorbing other
works and then your own interpretation
when someone paints a picture and uses
the tool you know paints or a paintbrush
or whatever it is they're using now
people can do all sorts of different
crazy art they'll take like coins and
then line them up so it makes a big
picture
the AI is just basically a paintbrush
what you input into it may not actually
be good art you might say hey make this
picture it makes one you say hey
everybody look what my AI thing did and
you're like that's stupid and then
someone might put it in refine it put
the photo back in say change this change
that and then refund to the point where
it actually makes a really cool picture
but admittedly it's just getting easier
and easier to make stuff the scary thing
about it is if all art is just
derivative of other art then eventually
all art will be derivative of ai ai will
just be regurgitating the same things
without new human thought and input but
it's it's crazy because I mean we like I
I've been working on stuff with like
different logos and we are working with
a graphic designer like an actual person
to come up with stuff and then one day I
was like you know I'm just going to try
one of these AI logo generators I just
want to see because we're kind of like
we're at an impasse where nothing's
really like sparking man the AI ones
were good oh wow they were really good
they were better there's like man this
is actually solid and it's faster and
it's cheaper but you know I want to
support for the actual person but it's
just hard when the AI product is in a
lot of ways genuinely better I want to
point out a couple articles real quick
because uh we're talking about threads
and uh even though a bunch of people on
the left are are trying to abandon
Twitter for this
look at this one from Vice I've seen
posts who people wouldn't believe the
birth of an awful Mutant baby a man
explaining the symptoms of acute
radiation poisoning are similar to panic
all those moments will be lost in time
like post from 2012. this is this is
they're talking about threads it says
threads is an assault on the senses once
you've experienced it it's impossible to
scrub from memory threads is a
kaleidoscope of disturbing images and
unpleasant information a cautionary tale
to be avoided and a revelation of truth
that feels Stark and unavoidable
I like this one too look at this slate
writes meta's new threads app is
terrible it just might bury Twitter the
first sentence is good the second
sentence is bad but uh yeah it is it is
absolutely awful if you can't even get
the left to cheer for this app dude I
don't know what you're gonna I think
they really messed up by opening up the
fire hose of data to new users and
making them see tons of people that they
weren't interested in rather than give
them like five categories have them Auto
subscribe to like five accounts or ten
accounts and let them find their way
because having to block people the
minute you walk into a social network is
the most anti-social tactic or technique
you do not want your users blocking each
other that's like a failure of the
system well so here's the thing with uh
with threads right so like you know
again I'll pull it up
and if I go to my my home feed let's
just see uh who we end up with like
Paris Hilton
I I don't care to follow Paris Sultan
but I don't want to block paracels
exactly right because at some point in
the future Paris might do something that
gets re-threaded or whatever and and you
know maybe run for president it's like I
want to see that post then I got to be
like oh they did I better go unblock
them to see it that's ridiculous but
that's what happens when it's a bunch of
random people I mean what is why is it
recommending Taylor Lorenz to me what is
this scraped your name on the Internet
with along with Taylor what is this is
Taylor Lorenz band
oh if if Taylor rents is on threat on
thread I or threads what's it called
threads I might have to sign up because
she's obvious I'm blocked on Twitter and
I miss her posts oh her neurotic
neurotic that'd be great yeah I'm still
trying to download it there's oh yeah
like no one used to search for Taylor
Lorenz you get it's like it's like why
would I why are you sending me this why
are you telling me to follow this person
I don't care it's a uh Instagram an
oversight or just a Brute Force tactic
well it's hard now because social media
isn't what it was created like Facebook
used to be the people that you know now
something like Twitter yeah it's a
mixture of people you know but also just
like Brands public figures like
political discourse it's this weird how
do you even begin to start to recommend
a person something I admit like not that
I'm trying to defend threads but that
does sound like a challenge you know the
worst thing about Instagram is you'll
click the little magnifying glass button
it'll give you a bunch of recommended
posts
you'll see this video this happens to be
a bunch where it's like I can't really
tell exactly what it is they do that on
purpose click on it they want you to
click it and then as soon as I do now
Instagram's sending me a whole bunch of
these weird videos like there's there
was one where it's uh because I watch a
lot of Poker Vlogs and so I get
recommended this video where I have no
idea what the picture is and I want to
know it is a coin pusher a fake a fake
coin pusher with fake casino chips in it
all I see is this weird stack of chips
and I'm like what is that so I hit it
and then I'm like oh it's a fake
gambling it's not real people make these
fake videos that look like they're
winning money because people click on it
and I'm like I get out of here next time
we refresh all of a sudden Instagram in
my main feed is sending me all this
garbage and I'm like block block I don't
want to see that I never wanted to see
it I just didn't know what it was this
is what they do how stupid of a social
media platform but they want a control
narrative and they want to shove
everybody into this algorithmic feed
that's why they're doing it I I mean I
wonder if the the debut of this
particular app is in conjunction with
the kicking off of the election season
probably you know it does make sense
um I mean I don't want to be too tinfoil
hat but if this is a social media uh app
that they can convince the regular
public is where the correct narrative is
and Twitter is where the misinformation
is then it might be an attempt to I'm
not saying it's going to be successful
it won't be because
so the thing about Twitter is it's where
the uh politically oriented individuals
seek out those conversations
threads they they can't do it Macedon
couldn't do it blue sky couldn't do it
threads won't be able to do it for all
of the same reasons any other app can't
do it Twitter is first in best dressed
and it's where people have followers and
it's where they talk I got no followers
on on threads and I really don't care to
try and get followers on a feed where
people won't even see what I post even
if I get a million followers
No One's Gonna see what I post because
it's all recommended weird algorithmic
stuff that's another they're
recommending AOC to me I do not want to
follow people are getting mauled by data
when they go in there man they need an
open space to seek out what they like
listen to me Mark wake up no no he knows
what he's doing I don't think he does
this is oh terrible debut it's got a 3.9
out of five ratings do you do not you
cannot give someone like Mark Zuckerberg
credit as he doesn't I mean granted the
social network was just a movie but it
kind of gave you an idea of like his
mindset and if you look at what he has
done with Facebook since like the end
point in that movie like he's installed
Facebook as the internet for a huge
portion of the developing world you know
he had a deal where if you go and and
use like they'll give out free phones
and these phones come with Facebook
installed so there's a huge portion of
the uh of the developing world that
their first experience with the internet
was on Facebook to a lot of people
um Facebook is the internet that to them
they're one in the same because that was
there for the the first way that they
experienced the internet so it's mostly
people who are on the older side like
young people gen Z they aren't as much
on Facebook I think you're right in like
Western countries but I think that like
in Africa and play and the Middle East
where you're talking about poorer
countries where they were all they're
all about tick tock
I'm not saying no no I'm I'm not saying
they they not I'm talking about like
when the reason that Facebook got to the
the right market share that it did was
because or like in in 2012 13 14 when
they were first like when they were
handing out phones with Facebook install
they were they're handing them out to
the developing world and that's why you
got so much of the whole world on
Facebook but it was partially because
not just that the app was worked well
and people liked it but because Facebook
was giving away phones with their their
product on it so that way they could
collect data because it was the you know
the the easiest way to collect people's
data is to give them a free phone with a
free and they'll just give you their
data they'll put it in for you and so
that that was that was one of the things
that Facebook did to really grab market
share and that's why Facebook is such a
big company and that's why you know a
lot of people think of the internet or
when they think of yeah when they think
of the internet they think of Facebook
were you saying that I was giving Mark
too much credit yeah he knew what he was
doing he knew that when he was giving
out those phones he was giving them away
for free because he wanted the data
those people had but with threads I
don't know if he's like yeah have it
opened every he might have made that
final call like let's just open it to
everybody let them just we'll start with
everything and they can work their way
back as opposed to start with nothing
and they can work their way up because
it's a very empty feeling to go into a
new social network and have nothing and
be like I don't even know what I'm doing
here who's on this network how do I find
them yeah but if you can import your
Instagram yeah then you that's what I
thought would happen and it is yet still
they give you a bunch of garbage you
don't want to read it's wow I think the
problem is that you were talking about
earlier the people that you follow on
Instagram aren't necessarily the people
you would follow on threads like they're
different things like on Instagram I
follow like baby accounts cake accounts
like travel and stuff which is very very
different than my my doomsday Twitter
curation it also ruins a lot of these
accounts for me because there's like
there'll be like one account where it's
just like people who you know travel the
world or whatever and they get to see
cool pictures of mountains and now
they're all of a sudden posting about
BLM or something and I'm like oh I did
not want to know your opinions I didn't
I do you have good content I don't care
about what your thoughts are you have no
idea what you're talking about you just
just ruin it for me that's why I like on
Instagram I I don't post any kind of
political stuff on my Instagram page I
never had like it's never been like very
very very rarely will I put something
mildly political political stuff stays
on Twitter and then you know Instagram
is Me and All That Remains and and shows
and my dog and stuff yeah I do cats did
you you like side surf cakes you ever
follow those guys they make kicks
they'll make cakes of like hyper real
realistic looking like a cup uh and then
you cut it and it's a cake they made Lex
Friedman's face oh that's pretty for
like and Michael malice had it at his
house he's probably still has it right
now yeah I posted a picture of it
they're great I follow that account
there's a lot of cake accounts yeah like
you like those realistic cake accounts I
mean I I like to follow them because
it's cool but I also know that those are
not the cakes that taste good right
because there's like a lot of fondant
and they're probably only moist because
they use a simple syrup I have like no I
like the like the Gen was the fluffier
yeah real cake yeah garbage do you do
are you a cook yes I love cooking I love
eating baking Ian not as good but still
like yeah why don't we talk about
politics because we're gonna get into
that uh a little bit ago here's the
story from the Daily Mail
White House cocaine was found near the
situation room and not in the West Wing
visitor entrance drug story changes for
the second time as secret service now
says Dimebag was found in a more secure
location okay so it was Hunter right
yeah I mean I I struggle to imagine
anyone else who was just sneaking in
cocaine to the White House because I
would imagine I've never been there but
I imagine they have pretty good security
I imagine there are cameras I imagine
people are getting searched yeah we're
the cameras I bet anything it was Jill
of what the video of Hunter on on the
balcony yeah it kind of looks like he's
kind of strung out he's you know well
then he goes a picture of uh let me
actually let me pull this up this video
is great he goes behind Jill and it
looks like he pulls his sleeve up takes
a bump off his arm and it also looks
like Jill is furious which I mean if
your son was strung out you probably
would be like if she can sense him
behind her and she's just in a mood
she's like this guy not in a mood
in a mood because of the right term take
a look at this picture Victor she
tweeted wow this photo of President
Biden sitting on the White House steps
is just so breathtaking and captures
this moment so well Joe Budden is doing
so much for all of us and has the weight
of the world on his shoulders and I just
want to say thank you every time I see
him so so here's this here's this one
the sentiment I got from this was Joe
sat down
looked at the Horizon and went damn that
was my Coke
like he's like damn it you Hunter you
can't just go I got it 45 minutes
without blowing lines up your nose I
said he was thinking something like that
you know Hunter he's I wonder if I don't
know if you can I assume a lot from a
picture but I imagine that Joe's just
like so broken about what he has be like
what happened with Hunter and and the
world knows there's video of Hunter like
there's pictures off his laptop with
little young people like chill kids well
that's what's crazy about the whole
Hunter Biden story not necessarily that
he's into all of this depravity but it's
that he feels the Apparently compulsive
need to document all of it like I mean
I've never seen a man take so many
incriminating selfies in my whole life
you know I understand it though because
you know I skateboard and so we're
always trying to film everything we do
to make sure everybody knows just you
know how good we are at skateboarding
and how good you are at the cracks like
well here's the thing man you know
Hunter Biden is a big part of the crack
community and he wants to make sure
everybody knows he's the best if you're
that good at smoking crack you want
people to know you know he goes to his
buddy and he's like yo I need to film
her because we're going to be doing
cracking prostitutes later tonight
someone's got to get capture this stuff
and they're like I just use your phone
put on Instagram and he's like all right
I was thinking about like the Roman
Republic or the Roman Empire really how
they would have like these giant parties
and on boats like when it was all
falling apart there's just these
decadent things and then we see this
Festival of Joe Biden just like vacantly
staring out his wife not even looking at
his son who's a crackhead who just got
like not pardoned but like a misdemeanor
for having like crack and a gun on him
and the how they'll look back at this
period of history at that and be like
wow what did America become that the
first son was like just given a little
pat on the wrist for having something
that would have thrown other people yeah
yeah I left his response to that was
that it's actually it's because of white
privilege nothing to do with Joe Biden
and Corruption because of that it's
specifically because Hunter is white
because all white people would have been
treated the same and Ian it very very it
may very well be that in a hundred years
the way they look back on this moment is
it was the beginning of the Fall yeah uh
I think the Kennedy assassination was
there they they they perhaps will write
in the future and say kids ah there's
always something the first fall of the
American Empire started in what date and
they're going to be like July 4th 2023
and what caused it finding Hunter
Biden's cocaine that's right kids it is
pretty nasty it's like what kind of
faith can you have I mean it obviously
power this is what I've always been told
they they protect each other people in
power nepotism runs rampant and they
flaunt it and I think this is Hunters
flaunting it obviously with all his
pictures and of propaganda and then
Joe's just completely ignoring it and
saying he's my son well they said they
found it near the West executive
entrance I think it's a lie I'm used by
officials visitors and celebrities yeah
I don't believe yeah and next thing you
know they're gonna be like at first
there was a library then that was The
West Wing Now situation room we found it
we found it on Biden we literally found
it in his pocket or they'll say it was
something other than cocaine next
they'll be like it was actually baked
King soda we thought it was coke it
wasn't
I mean what what a bunch of crap why
would they even tell us anyway why would
they even bring this up because they
don't they don't want they want to
replace Biden
they're getting rid of a mic drop I
think you're right dude yeah it's
probably gonna be Newsome or something
yeah well he's he's going on a
nationwide tour he was doing some uh
something I think it was in Idaho and
Boise where he was uh visiting a
bookstore like oh look at these banned
books like you're at a bookstore the
books are not banned if they're at a
bookstore but I mean there's no reason
he's doing anything outside of
California unless he wants to run for
president what do you think about
Michelle Obama
um I think so she doesn't really have
the experience or the gravitas that
Barack did but there's a lot of
nostalgia around the Obama presidency
for I think like a lot of Independence
probably disaffected liberals so I think
I mean if it's her or Kamala definitely
Michelle Obama yeah yeah but the truth
is if you're
if you have Nostalgia for Obama you
didn't pay attention to Obama's
presidency oh yeah I'm not denying that
but I think there are like a lot of
disaffected liberals or people who would
not vote Democrat now who were happy to
vote for Obama regardless of how things
were going just because it it felt nice
you know he he felt like a president and
it was the good old days back then even
though it wasn't in a lot of ways partly
why some people probably voted for Biden
yeah because they were thought it was
going to be like Obama or whatever but
it's probably going to be Newsome we'll
see though I mean I really don't know
it's it's worth it I feel like that
would be such a hard sell because you
are governor of a state that is bleeding
hemorrhaging people it's it's it's just
going down the drain who on Earth would
look at California and think yes if you
it's you know there are people who live
in these places yeah and they keep
defending what's going on it's
remarkable when we have a conversation
with some of these liberals people live
in New York and it's like 25 people were
pushed in front of subway trains last
year like that's bad and they're like so
what and I'm like you don't have we
don't I'm not arguing every single
person in Manhattan is falling in front
of trains I'm saying you probably should
do something to stop this from happening
yeah well I think what's frustrating
about talking to people from New York
and California especially is that they
act like those things are normal like I
remember there was uh oh gosh what it
was with Jordan Neely right uh this
homeless guy was threatening people
there are so many New Yorkers who are
saying well that's just normal that's an
everyday occurrence he didn't need to
freak out I was like what is the matter
with you people you don't need to live
like this there are so many other places
even other cities where this doesn't
happen stop defending it and it's also
frustrating because these are the people
who by and large hate America the most
and it's like you are in a blue City in
a blue State when the president is a
Democrat if things aren't going well
perhaps step back and take a look at why
that is I'm kind of excited for
everything that's going on with politics
because I'm feeling like you know we're
winning with with the Bud Light stuff
especially and I do think we're going to
start to see more liberal personalities
start adopting the disaffected liberal
stances on things because at a certain
point they're going to realize
they there's no market for the weird
leftist stuff I mean I'll put it this
way
eight years ago it was intersectional
feminism you know critical race Theory
now it's wokeness gender ideology it
keeps whatever like what it keeps
changing what the left wants they have
they have no position it's just random
and amorphous at a certain point as they
keep getting crazier and more unhinged
with whatever with whatever it is
they're supporting
people are leaving Liberals are becoming
disaffected and that means these
commentators are going to lose their
positions and they're going to be forced
to be like okay that's too much for me
well I think people are starting to wake
up because I follow this is just a very
anecdotal thing but I follow a lot of
makeup brands on things like Instagram
just because you know it's it's fun it's
girly whatever but during pride month
it's insufferable every makeup Beauty
brand any brand that caters to women
they're all out trans this uh let's put
men in our products whatever I started
actually looking through the comments
because I was just unfollowing Brands
because I'm sick of it I started looking
through the comments expecting this is
brave like you know because by and large
women at least on social media they all
eat that stuff up but no overwhelmingly
people were fed up saying unfollow what
does this have to do with the product
and I think that's a good like even
normies are getting sick of it normies
who are probably left right women are
getting turfy like I literally just just
this morning I got a text message from a
buddy of mine who's in a very well-known
band and he's like he's me a a tweet
from from Jill flipovic and she was
talking about you know about how
marriages are are not you know people
aren't getting married in there and they
don't last and and she was looking at
this as a as a victory because she
thinks that women are out there doing
what they want to do and living their
lives even though everybody it seems
that people are more depressed and not
happy about it but anyways she was
looking at it as a as a victory in my
buddy's like do you believe this stuff
and I'm like look
this is this is kind of how the the left
go goes they don't actually embrace
things like family values and he's you
know he's he's got a family and he's
talking about his his wife and he's like
she's he's like you know she's kind of
turfy and stuff and and I was like look
the she was talking about women and uh
men in in women's bathrooms and stuff
and that's where the line is being drawn
women want to have their own spaces yeah
you could probably get away with
bathrooms maybe you're not gonna get
away with locker rooms you're not
getting away with dudes with with trans
women in the G in the gym locker room
walking around with a boner
we Spa remember yeah exactly it's
exactly so that turned out to actually
not be a trans person it was just a guy
who liked flashing his junk at women and
so because of these policies and it's
funny because conservatives are like
what's going to stop a man from doing it
or whatever and they're all like the
left says trans people don't do these
things like right we're concerned about
the men doing it under the guise yeah so
what happens is this dude goes in the
women's locker room flashing his junk
and when a woman complains they're like
must be a trans person so we're not
going to do anything about it then it
turns out to be a repeat offender they
arrest if they if it is a trans person
or if it is a trans person they do
something imagine what they're gonna get
on social media the backlash the you're
transphobic Etc all the all of the
incentive is to allow the person in the
bathroom to do whatever it is that they
want just as long as they don't actually
physically grab someone else because the
repercussions of being wrong or being
accused of being transphobic
suicide let me tell you guys something
the uh first ever 1080 on a skateboard
was done by I think a 12 year old boy
12. this is like pre-pubescent it's like
there's no you know they say puberty is
the is the point or whatever
the 12 year old boy this tremendous feat
where are the females
if puberty is what matters so recently a
I think a 12 year old girl did the first
ever 720 on avert ramp 720 okay so for
those that are not familiar with this
what this means when you spin a full
rotation around it's a 360 you're
spinning 360 Degrees you did that twice
at 720 you do three times to 1080. just
this in this past week or so a a 12 year
old girl did a 720 annivert ramp the
first time a girl's ever done it it was
a huge deal everyone's screaming and
cheering and I find it duplicitous
to celebrate the first female to do a
720 at the same time they're celebrating
males competing in women's sports
you recognize the the literal
distinction between males and females
because if it really was that there it
doesn't matter if you're male or female
they would have been like who cares that
a female did a 720 a 12 year old boy did
a 1080. and then I think another guy did
1260 a couple years ago which was a
really real big deal
but the reality is because they know
females are not competing at the same
level as males what's going to happen
when we've already had uh if you guys
have been following Taylor Silverman who
actually works here she was competing
skateboarding contest and had lost
contests to biological males
how can this contradiction exist but
I'll tell you the frustrating thing
about it
people in the skateboard industry at the
highest levels will privately privately
say yeah we're not okay with this stuff
and then publicly be like Yay good for
you
that's starting to change yeah and
that's the cultural shift we're seeing
and I'm actually happy to see because
now people are finally being like okay
we can't keep doing this but what's
Insidious is that on the left I've
already seen the next evolution of their
argument it's like At first though
there's no difference you don't you
don't need to worry about men uh taking
over women's sports because they don't
have an advantage now it's like okay
they do have an advantage but that is
exactly why kids need to go on puberty
blockers it's so that the advantage
isn't I guess instilled but that that is
BS because at least according to my
pediatrician or my kids pediatrician
from birth boys and girls are on
different growth charts from from
conception men and women are different
actually in in utero right prenatal
testosterone has a big impact on fast
fast twitch muscle development for
instance um listen I don't think that
children should be put on puberty
blockers until they're old enough to
decide what gender they want to be but I
want the left to make that argument real
bad I want them to make that argument
real bad because they will die at The
Ballot Box regarding like winning like
right now that the call it feels like
things have changed like there's a a sea
change and whether it's a winning it's
like an ingredient of winning it's like
the Anvil is so hot right now we have
heated this system up by uncovering the
problems and Hyper focusing on them and
teaching people about the problems now
it is hot now it is time to strike and
that is to create some sort of cultural
revolution that is in the mind easy with
with those kind of well this is what now
and pull in the cultural revolution talk
but that's what's happening right now
and we have to guide it no no Evolution
that's happening regardless of whether
you want it or not the question is is
the outcome going to be preferable to
you yes and we need we need to push back
against the people that are trying to
have a cultural revolution in the US
because the cultural revolution is in a
an illiberal Direction what we want is
we want liberal principles in America
and right now the push in the cultural
revolution is an authoritarian push it's
where the censorship comes from it's
where the shutting people down comes
from all that stuff is authoritarian and
it's ill liberal and it's not what we
want but we need a new way of of living
life in the okay for instance kids are
seeing porn at the age of nine we need
some sort of sexual education Revolution
no no no no we need to uphold the law
laws as they've been forever you can't
just I mean if you just blame no no no
it's gonna overcome something you just
said no no and then you said we need to
hold the line in the middle of me
explaining my position so I cut you off
sorry you said we need to have a sexual
education for nine-year-olds no what
needs to happen is it has always been
illegal to allow children into adult
movie stores and bookstores Etc sure and
then one day the internet internet gets
invented and then everyone in our in our
country just goes now it's fine well no
no no it's not fine websites that allow
children to access that stuff should be
prosecuted the same way a bookstore with
a pair it's the parents that are
allowing it that's the problem yeah but
it you could say it's the parents that
are allowing it when it comes to
pornography but if a little kid were to
go into a into a supermarket and buy
alcohol you wouldn't just say oh it's
the parents that need to do it no yeah
but the parents let them do it but it
would still be illegal to sell alcohol
to that minor regardless of what the
parents wanted or not why is there a
different standard for online
pornography because that's also not the
standard for in-person pornography if
you can't just oh it's the parent's
fault so sorry go ahead no no I don't
want to cut you off let me just saying
like that's only oh it's just the
parents fault to moderate that's really
only used when it comes to online
pornography people aren't saying that
when it comes to like actual uh porn
that you could buy in person right we're
okay with the government saying no you
as the seller cannot provide that to the
minor how about this if a guy goes out
in public in a trench coat and starts
dancing around and then whips his coat
open and he's naked he gets arrested
yeah how about during a pride parade
that's true How about if a guy goes on
Twitter and posts a video of him dance
and then whips it open he gets arrested
there's literally no difference well I'm
talking about is more it's just about
educating young people about sexuality
in a way that can help them that no
because actually that's important please
let me finish it sounded like you did
finish no I mean okay so you made a
point then he started talking but what
when I was like 11 or 10 I had sex ed in
fifth grade and they were like this is
what a condom looks like good luck kids
don't get her pregnant and I'm like okay
I guess that's enough for the 90s but
now if the kid's friend brings a cell
phone and they're all going to see porn
like you they need to know they need to
be but you can't just bolster it against
that you can't just start treating
nine-year-olds like they would
inevitably be looking at porn at the
time right because that's the same
that's basically saying like oh well
you're going to see porn anyway we might
as well just and now honestly like
honestly the the biggest problem that I
have with that is this is something that
parents should be deciding like parents
should be deciding when their kids get
you know get are given sexual education
but that that is not something that's
the mental Revolution exactly we need a
mental revolution of the Consciousness
where people are open become open to
communicating these kinds of things with
their kids right the argument you're
making is that because
Pete there are people out in the streets
exposing their genitals to children it's
important that we have the conversation
with our kids about why they're doing it
I would rather stop the pets actually
exposing themselves the police go and
arrest those people like no that's not
the argument I'm talking about internet
porn yes it's the same thing no no no
it's not a guy on the street flashing is
not the same as Internet porn I agree
you can watch internet porn from your
living room you can't watch a guy on the
street flashing from your living room
you gotta go on the street through your
window right but you have to go there in
public in public is in public Twitter is
in public the street is from your closet
with the door closed you can watch
internet porn you cannot see the
internet is in public that's an argument
that needs to be made not a lot of
people our courts have made that right
that's why they said that Donald Trump
can't block people but yet AOC has
blocked people and and it's it's so it's
continuing it's considered to be a
violation of a court order that has to
be adjudicated but but the difference
between a politician barring you from a
public space which is a civil civil
matters that the same as someone Expo
posing themselves to Children which is
what people who go on Twitter and post
porn are literally doing so I don't know
why it is that before the internet it
was ubiquitous anyone who goes out into
public and exposes themselves male or
female two kids to any person would get
arrested the internet gets invented
anyone can access it from anywhere with
with increasing uh with increasing ease
and all of a sudden with civilization
decided this one area doesn't count no
way dude it is in public and there
should be uh look I'll put it this way
the laws are already clear the laws are
already on the books you cannot expose
yourself to children or to anybody
but the police don't actually enforce
the law
the police should
the police should fix it like you got to
save your kids before they get corrupted
and that's not that's just protect their
mindset argument yeah if you can't just
call on the police who the hell is that
anyway like what are they gonna do
arrest the people who are posting
pornography
your argument is because we've allowed
it we should not stop no because it is
reality we need to craft such it's we
can't pretend that it's not it's reality
there are people going the street and
expose themselves it is reality and we
need to confront it but why is the way
that we are confronting it by making it
a problem children have to deal with if
we are going to confront it we should
tackle things from the adult perspective
and handle the adults who are committing
the ACT rather than just trying to train
our kids like oh I'm sorry you're just
gonna have people flashing you and it's
not okay but I guess we'll talk to you
about it so yeah you're prepared but
also there are states like Virginia I
think was the most recent one I think
Utah has done the same where now they
are requiring age verification to access
sites like PornHub and it's this whole
thing because now PornHub is like okay
well we're gonna block IP addresses from
those states which I mean obviously
everyone has a VPN it's very easy to get
around but uh you know some people are
saying now oh it's it's because it's a a
threat to privacy yada yada yada but I
mean you have to show your idea if
you're going to purchase alcohol or
access adult stuff in person
I don't think it's unreasonable to say
that those same standards should apply
when online well I got a question I I
posed the suggestion that we need a
revolution of the way we teach sexual
education to kids if you guys disagree
and you think we don't need to change
anything no no but it seems it seems
like you want a revolution in the
opposite way yeah you're you're taking
the approach the left takes I'm taking
well I don't know I don't know what I I
taken a person by person basis but I
think that you need you need to get kids
ready they need to understand that why
why do you need to get kids ready to
understand hold on I'm sorry I'm trying
to interrupt go ahead Ian's right we
need to start showing kids graphic
videos of people getting their heads
blown off in war because that's reality
too
and they might they might be out in the
streets of Chicago as a lot of gun
violence and death so it's about time
you bring these kids over and you show
them these videos and explain to them
what they're seeing and why or how about
this we protect children from these
things be it Gore or looting lascivious
behaviors and when people engage in
stuff in public we say hey that breaks
the law okay how's it working so far
we're not doing it we've never done it
like my point is our society in this
country for some reason decided that
even though the internet is publicly
accessible to children we won't do
anything about people posting graphic
images in places children can reach it
is on the books that you cannot have a a
weapon a gun accessible to children in
many states
you can make arguments about whether or
not second amendment protects the rights
of people to keep and bear arms or those
people our children or not but there are
those laws they exist yet for some
reason the left which wants to ban guns
will Advocate to an extreme degree that
you cannot have a weapon in any way this
could mean that you can't put it on the
top shelf of your closet and close the
door kid could get in there but when it
comes to posting graphic obscene I'm not
talking about two people in the
missionary position the stuff you can
find on the internet everybody knows how
psychotic it is dude how absolutely man
that you can't even I wouldn't even
mention on on YouTube yes and so we we
created as a society section 230
specifically so that these platforms
could remove those things and not be
held personally uh liable for
suppressing speech it's a bit more
complicated than that but it was like if
something is lewd and obscene you can
take it down and not be considered
responsible for the speech on that
platform
yet we've never set the precedent that
yo you can't walk around in public
showing big pictures of of pornography
you can't do that but you can do it on
the internet where children can get
access to it and not not just about
children if if Ian is kind of held up
like oh well maybe children should have
more education even as an adult right
you you can be charged for indecent
exposure if there's no children around
but why is it all right to I mean spam
pornography on on Twitter to threads
that have nothing to do with pornography
why is that considered different
uh I with Twitter I don't know if you
need to be 18 to use the app that's 13.
yeah 13. yeah do you need parental
consent I I think there are states that
are beginning I think Utah now or like I
forget the exact type of states are
beginning to say okay you need you do
need parental consent to be on social
media if you're under a certain age but
that is not like a twitter-wide policy
as far as I'm concerned people can
correct me on the street there's no like
18 and over sign before you go there on
PornHub there is so you can't go you're
well you can go but you're supposed to
survive it's like two little kids with
one on the other shoulders and a trench
coat walk into an adult bookstore and go
well I guess I am 20 years old oh right
this way sir but what it feels like is
that there's like an alien presence
that's infiltrating our system and
people are like make it stop make it go
away you're like dude they've already
infiltr this is not an American thing
this is like a local sexy the alien
presence is called horny yeah whoever's
running these websites I don't pin them
on America and like we can try and use
American defense mechanisms to stop it
but it's there right now and it's
happening so we need to at least
understand it and we need to understand
it as as soon as possible I'm not saying
show kids graphic images I'm not saying
that but I think that we just need to re
we need a new way of living and behaving
in this new dude they want to put people
in machine pods they want to control
your brain thoughts we need to we need
to take control of this you're you're a
little jumping around here look what I'm
getting from you is you're you're you
keep you say that there needs to be a
revolution I take issue with the idea of
having a revolution just but I mean a
revolution already happened to be clear
with the internet and the way that
people are accessing they're they're
yeah yes but and again I take issue
because you're not talking about like a
technological Revolution or Industrial
Revolution you're talking about a a
people Revolution a revolution or at
least that's what that's what I'm
understanding it's also what Mao says
yeah it's a Consciousness Revolution
it's why I started doing YouTube in
2006. we don't need a Consciousness
Revolution we need to we need to to
disregard and and reject things that we
know do not work things like top down
control having uh government in charge
of educating children those are things
that we need to avoid you want to have a
family Focus you want your your Society
wants to have a family Focus it's not a
bad idea to say all right you can't post
graphic images on this website and if
you do then it's actionable you know by
the police because this is the Public
Square or at least it makes sense right
that like maybe I'm I'm not for that
particular policy or whatever but it is
a policy that it does address what seems
to be the issue that we're talking about
which is children being exposed to
graphic images and pornography on there
on on the internet I agree that we need
to stop things that are bad we do that's
a scientific way of looking at it
doesn't work you disregard it that's the
scientific method but there are other
things that we can't we don't know if
they work or not like God it's just
people grow up not believing that it's
real they think it's fake and and I
don't think it is fake anymore I I don't
it seems like there's some some sort of
essence that's moving I mean human words
let's stand topic I guess well this is
the Consciousness Revolution I'm talking
about we need this in in people's soul
in their Spirit we need to the level of
fearlessness or what this is something
that that sounds very personal to you
and the idea that that we should assert
that everyone needs to have a
Consciousness Revolution because of
something that you feel but I mean
deeply impersonal about thank you that's
not good I bet Mao tried to make
everyone experience it well that's
that's the thing it's like trying to
remake man clear what you are saying and
advocating for top down control is bad
government control of education is bad
for that to not be our reality that
would necessitate a revolution because
that is what we are living in it is a
radical thing nowadays to say let's
abolish the Department of Education like
that is a revolutionary thing because we
are so entrenched in this system right
now uh well okay so I mean if you if you
understand that as revolutionary okay I
can accept that I mean in what way isn't
not revolutionary because we had a
125 or whatever 150 years
right now require a complete overhaul of
the system pardon me would it right now
require a complete overhaul of the
system no because you've got you've got
the you've got no you've got schools
schools are mostly even though the
Department of Education kind of is is is
is is the like the government agency
yeah but there's still a lot of autonomy
that schools have the biggest problem
that I've met Department of Education is
the federal level but then there's all
of the state apparatuses yeah I mean
that's something that the the government
the problems that I have mostly with the
with the curriculum and stuff is coming
from the people that are producing the
curriculum not as much in this in the
the state the state apparatus the state
apparatus is deciding on the curriculum
but I think even there's like a little
bit of government control in education I
well no I usually you should completely
have the people should have the the I
mean I'm a guy that wants to abolish the
Department of Education like that's been
something that I've been Pro you know
doing clearly for for as long as I've
been on the uh on the internet but I
think that there isn't any reason to
have centralized control over education
at all and people can homeschool their
kids there's no reason to demand that
people have to go to government schools
or anything let me cap this off when I
talked about Revolution what I'm really
thinking of like the Age of
Enlightenment that was another that's a
revolution that was a revolution of
Consciousness and I want something like
that
to turn forward Revolution means to turn
forward to turn again to revolute it's a
French term yeah I mean Latin like I
said my My Vibe is what I'm hearing you
express is that you believe there needs
to be a Awakening inside people and and
what to me sounds like remaking man and
every time Society or man has tried to
reinvent human beings remake man it's
ended in piles and piles and piles of
bodies I want to jump to this story we
have this tweet from Alx breaking the
Mind Administration has officially filed
a notice of appeal in the Missouri V
Biden censorship case if their federal
judge issued a preliminary injunction
order barring government officials from
contacting social media companies to
suppress lawful speech simply put this
is the Biden administration's notice of
appeal
seeking to effectively overturn the
right of freedom of speech in this
country the First Amendment yes why the
judge said you are still allowed to
contact all of these companies for
issues of National Security and just not
for suppressing the speech of of U.S
citizens
the appeal specifically means the Biden
Administration wants the right to
suppress the speech of American citizens
this is where we're currently at the New
York Times takes the amazing approach
that uh it's bad
we should allow the government to stop
people from speaking their minds that's
where we're currently at in this country
so you want to talk about a twisted
reality we have people who
here's where Democrats are they quite
literally don't care if people are
bringing into schools books depicting
adult
carnal activities and this information
to kids they literally don't care that a
teacher was trying to give students
instruction or literally to give
students instruction how to use Grindr
which is an 18 and up app only they
literally do not care of these things
they don't care that kids are getting
access to
psychotic and obscene graphic
pornography
I'm not just talking about as I
mentioned earlier like two two people in
a bedroom the stuff you can find online
is insane they don't care about any of
that what they don't want you to do is
criticize Joe Biden what they don't want
you to do is point out the hunter Biden
laptop story what they don't want you to
do is point out that they actually want
to censor conservatives because if you
do those things they try to remove you
what they don't want you to do is
Advocate that children's not get sex
change surgery they'll ban you for that
too
but they don't care about all the
depravity
when I look at this stuff with what Joe
Biden is doing
it really does feel like we are looking
at
an evil mirror image of what this
country and what our uh our society has
believed in it's the antithesis of
everything we thought was good and moral
and just we want people to speak their
minds we don't want kids exposed to
graphic images what are the Democrats
advocating for the complete inversion
the suppression of individual rights in
speech and they Advocate children see
these things and that's just that's
that's just the beginning we can go on
to all the seven deadly sins too this is
shockingly insane well this has been
going on for a long time this is the
most transparently it's been I guess
reflected in government but even if we
look at Twitter before Elon Musk the
amount of resources they were dedicating
to controlling the narrative on the
vaccine or election interference versus
the amount of resources they were
dedicated to actually you know shutting
down uh you know child exploitation
material it absolutely shows where their
priorities are they don't actually care
about people's well-being it's all about
controlling the narrative so you know
children being exposed to any type of
graphic thing being exploited online
that doesn't really harm their control
so they don't really do anything about
it but hey someone questioning the
efficacy of the facts that actually does
threaten their control so they they go
all in on devoting resources Manpower
finances whatever into controlling that
when you think of the government do you
think of it as a very powerful thing or
do you see it more as kind of like a
Visage of power I think I think it's a
very very powerful thing and I think
Americans are
they're naive as to how all Encompass
how all-encompassing the government
really is in their day-to-day lives
infringing on their freedoms I mean
because yes America is a very free
country especially compared to somewhere
like even you know Canada or the UK but
to act as if the country now resembles
anything the founding fathers had in
mind no they would they're rolling in
their graves right now I I agree that we
need some form of censorship in kind of
tail backing off what you were saying
about how kids are seeing like graphic
images like okay we need to protect some
aspect of our of our culture of our life
of our species and that is through just
censorship but I just want to ask you
one quick question real quick do you
conceive of preventing children from
seeing pornography as censorship
I suppose it depends on how it's done
that could be one way to prevent them
from seeing it to say like you can't be
here it is censorship well I mean
another way like hey let's go out and
play tonight instead of being on the
computer that's not really censorship
the way that I this is only my
perception when I can like think of
censorship I think of something that is
try at least the effort is made to
prevent anyone from seeing it so like
kids being prevented from seeing adult
content to me that doesn't come across a
censorship because you prevent kids from
grabbing the the red hot stove because
it's you know it's not it's protecting
them
censorship doesn't need to be like
always negative or always positive it's
just restricting information I think
ratings on movies are a form of
censorship to let you know ahead of time
don't take your kid to see the R-rated
one well I mean like courts in the US
have ruled that you like pornography is
not free speech so I I guess I would
push back on the idea that restricting
pornography is because if it doesn't
technically infringe on your free speech
because pornography isn't speech
according to the courts is that actually
censorship
I think censorship is oh we got the
suppression or prohibition of any parts
of books films news Etc that are
considered obscene politically
unacceptable or a threat to security
which is that's like a half definition
you can censor and let things happen
like I can be like well I looked at the
video I'm the guy that owns the website
and I'm gonna let the video on I still
censored it I just didn't take it down I
censored it and allowed it to be there
right so here's ultimately the
ultimately the issue
censorship based on that definition the
other simple definition was restricting
access to images information books Etc
that are offensive
we find it offensive to show kids this
lewd and lascivious stuff we would like
that to be censored
the left Democrats Etc and liberals want
kids to see these things which I think
is psychotic and evil so they say we
oppose censorship however your naughty
words where you say something like I
disagree with with you and the way you
you are living your life I think is bad
for everyone they say that is shocking
and offensive and shouldn't be allowed
let me just put it this way
these people live in this world
for you and I for the people who watch
this show
it would seem to be insanity
of course we are offended at the thought
that children are getting access to
lewdness of his behavior of course we
are shocked that people try to restrict
our ability to have a political debate
in the left World they are absolutely
shocked we would try and stop children
from seeing these things how insane is
that it is insane I've had friends be
like what why do you want censorship
censorship's bad don't do no no
censorship and it's like yeah snap out
of it yeah you want to censor the bad
stuff of course but then who's deciding
what's bad is it what he said is what
she said someone what they said about my
kid like so who's censoring reality yeah
who's the who's the who's the sensor is
should we make it an algorithm like a an
open source artificial intelligence
that's giving advice to people this is
why it's a culture War because there are
two distinct moral Frameworks there is
the traditional American I would say
simply put judeo-christian moral
framework and then there is the leftist
there is no truth but Power moral
framework
it seems to be you know look it is
really simple in in some ways say a
thing and a leftist will say the exact
opposite for all the only reason of
opposing you
hence their positions change rapidly and
seem to make no sense
that that's just the reality of it well
there was a one of the crassenstein
brothers after that Viral clip of nudity
like exposed male genitalia I think it
was Seattle Pride one of them was
actually somewhat defending it and it's
like the there I can think of no other
reason why a sane person would be
defending a male exposure exposing
himself to minors if it were not a
leftist just contradicting the right
right and the crescentstein's Frozen
unfamiliar they're prominent liberal
personalities have tried taking this
more moderate Centrist approach and so
their approach to this was hey it's it's
it's probably not that big of a deal if
a kid sees nudity it happens a lot uh I
don't think someone should be riding
riding around nude in front of a bunch
of kids that's not a good thing but Libs
of tick tock sharing it is worse than
the guy doing it so it was still this
critique of Libs of tick tock that did
to a certain degree downplay the nudity
in front of kids I don't think it's
completely wrong for the crescents to
say that because kids go in locker rooms
all the time with with people who are
naked around them however her at an
event that is explicitly sexual in
nature with the intent of expressing
sexual like ideas then you're crossing a
line into grooming territory but my
point with the crescentsteins here to
add on to what you're saying is they're
just saying something critical of the
right for the sake of being critical of
the right it's this is the crazy thing
how hard would it be for any liberal to
say something like I want Universal
Health Care and then I go okay I have no
opinion on that what do you think about
these books yeah those books shouldn't
be for kids how hard is that they can't
do it they come on they come on the
culture War podcast or they come on this
show and they say something like I think
it's good and I'm like really why
you end up with that famous clip you end
up with the famous clip we had with
Lance from the serfs saying that women
should be allowed to get an abortion
whenever they want but that pregnant
women shouldn't be allowed to do math
because it kills the baby right now he's
like that's awesome because there's no
moral framework I think there are a lot
of people that would be considered on
the left or or you know liberal uh
culturally liberal that would be open to
talking exactly what you're saying Tim
like yeah okay universal healthcare
great this book probably shouldn't be
for kids great but it's the loudmouth
contrarians that are famous right now
and it's so annoying this tribalism is
like it's like binding it's like holding
people back it's like sticky goo on
their feet that they can't you can get
out of it but you got to realize
it's like all people too it's I saw
everywhere I look man in this political
crap is like the willingness to say no
like
not always sometimes yes and yes you can
both be right you know sorry Phil were
you about to say something you look like
you're about to say something uh no just
uh Tim said that
um Tim was saying that talking about
Lance and and I think that you gave uh
Lance too much credit but what do you
mean because there's no moral framework
yeah you said that he has no moral no
moral framework and that's true but I
don't think that the reason that you
know Lance said that dumb thing was
because of a lack of moral framework I
think it was just because Lance was
tired after using all of his brain power
to keep up for for the the conversation
that was just Lance not knowing that he
was going to be walked into a uh round
two is about to happen I I I I've talked
to a lot of people about the idea of
debates
it's the weirdest concept to me
you know like people have asked me like
I'm going to be debating this issue and
you know what do you think about this
argument I'm like do you believe what
you are saying like then what are you
asking me for if someone came here and
said did you know x y r z I'd be like I
didn't I'll look into it here's what I
believe like I don't it's this idea that
we're debating people just to appear
like we know what we're talking about
makes no sense to me so
I will have a conversation with quite
literally anybody and there is no
winning or losing a debate
is the difference between debate and
dialectic like are we talking to prove
the other wrong or are we talking
because we are both interested in
pursuing the truth and we maybe have
different versions of what it is and
we're trying to kind of Spar back and
forth to see how we can best get there
those are two very different I guess
approaches to have and that's I'm not I
I'm not that interested in like strictly
debate because there are formal debates
like Point Counterpoint Point
Counterpoint I don't think that's
productive but when you actually have
people who are having a conversation and
they could have opposing views but
they're trying to understand each other
and arrive at the truth that I think is
actually something interesting so this
is what happens Lance from the Surfs
comes on the show with the intent of
winning a debate we have him on the show
with the intent of him explaining how he
sees the world yeah the problem is he
doesn't actually know how he sees the
world he just knows how to regurgitate
talking points for the sake of debate
hence when it comes to the question of
abortion I can ask him 50 million
questions on what his logic is and he
can't answer it because he doesn't have
any he says arguments to what you might
say he he has he has pre-prescripted
arguments he had it written down I don't
write anything down people are like Tim
you did a really great job on on Rogan
with Dorsey and I'm like I prepared in
no way I researched nothing I showed up
and talked about what I thought
the you were um you were talking about
uh him coming and not being prepared and
the re and about uh how his his opinion
changes and stuff the left doesn't have
a foundational opinion on stuff because
of the fact that it's power games
there's no more moral framework yeah for
example when uh that that woman came on
the culture War I'm not gonna say her
name yeah and uh because I'm kind of
tired of it but she said the show
appeals to neo-nazis and then 10 minutes
later or half an hour later told uh
actual Justice Warrior that he was too
right-wing for this show because the
show was moderate quite literally saying
random words for the sake of saying
random words well no it's they're
they're not random they're all designed
to undermine so I mean it's it's in its
own way a consistent moral framework if
it's counter to the right and in its
pursuit of like their own power I mean
James Lindsay talks about that a lot
it's not a double standard it's one
consistent standard if it helps me to
help my cause if it's for the pursuit of
power then it is good this is why
Lance's abortion thing broke down in the
way it did because he doesn't have a
real position on abortion he has talking
point and so I with an actual position
on limits of government individual
rights constitutional rights when does
Life Begin and have all these views
where I've had many discussions about it
trying to understand it you can ask me a
million one questions and I will give
you an answer or outrighteous be like
you know what I'm not I'm not so sure
about that I just don't know and I bet
you're willing to change your opinion if
you find out something that might go
contrary to your existing world I can
guarantee that Tim is willing to change
his opinion although I've noticed it
doesn't always happen right away
sometimes we'll argue and I'll say
something where I'm like damn I was I
was good I was true and then like it'll
be like three days later you'll be like
yeah you'll see what I was talking about
doesn't always happen right away that's
an interesting phenomenon one good
example the smarter you are the longer
it takes to figure things out well that
means you're exactly you've memorized
what you believe sorry to interrupting
Sheamus and I are having a conversation
about abortion he expressed the
definition of abortion I argue with him
and told him I thought he was wrong and
that's this is not the case and he needs
to understand these points and then
after pulling up the information and I
was like oh Sheamus was right the whole
time but the definition of what abortion
is I was incorrect I had a different
view that was not based so Sheamus was
basing his views off of the actual
statements made by Planned Parenthood
and the government as to what abortion
is and I had a general assumption about
what people call it so I was not
understanding his point there's kind of
a phenomenon where when you figure out
you're wrong about something and you
figure out what it actually is that's
right there that little piece now you
have it's like exciting and invigorating
because you get to reform your belief in
a better way in a more correct way yeah
humiliating especially when it happens
in public and you're shown to be having
been wrong for so long and so vehement
about what you were wrong about but man
is it empowering if you if you use it
properly so this is this is what you see
and and we'll we'll uh give a good shout
out to our friends over at The Young
Turks because we were talking about this
the other day and uh Anna kasparian has
been been getting dragged quite a bit
because she said bonus hole as a term
for women's Parts is
off-putting but there's there's
something interesting in this have you
ever asked yourself why it is that these
neo-terms only ever apply to women and
never to men
because I think it's ultimately
intersectionality as it is now
especially with the Trans movement it is
unironically patriarchal right the best
women are men everything is done to the
comfort of males regardless of what they
call themselves they're ultimately males
and you do not see the same
considerations being given to trans men
I.E females I agree that it's
patriarchal but the reason I think that
it is
bonus hole menstruator birthing person
chest feeding have they have they called
men jizzers no they should they don't
say that why I believe this is
predominantly a movement of women it is
females who are pursuing these things
with a female internal perspective so
the words they use are based on their
experiences men typically do not care
so man aren't complaining about being
called names they're not proposing being
called something else it is females
typically and we see this in the data
when it comes to trans kids
overwhelmingly trans children tend to be
female
Perhaps it is a social issue of sorts
and that's why all of the Neo terms are
like menstruator bonus hole have her
it only pertains to women I don't think
that the phenomena of trans
trans women and trans men are the same
no they're not I think that yeah I think
that I I don't think the same stuff is
going on upstairs for a woman to want to
be to live their life as a man or
believe that they're a man or whatever I
mean that's for a woman as for a man
that thinks that they're a woman there
are vastly different rates in how men
versus women identify as being gay like
lesbian for example and also rates of
identifying as trans this is not
something new women and men do not
function in the same realm in regard to
sexuality they're really interesting
twin studies that they've done on um
like identical twins so if something
like sexuality were completely genetic
for example you would expect that any
genetic twin set would have the same
sexuality I.E both straight or both gay
what they found is that that's not the
case so there is obviously a component
that's determined by environment and
what they have found that it is much
more likely for a uh like a female set
of twins to have different sexualities
meaning that female sexuality is a lot
more fluid or easily influenced Maybe by
environment than male sexuality that's
kind of profound because it's a simple
concept that men and women that become
trans are experiencing different to the
point where they used to have gay well
they still do gay and lesbian it's the
same thing someone that enjoys sexuality
with the same sex homosexual but they
had yeah but they have different words
completely different words it's a gay
man I guess you would say a gay man or a
gay woman but a lesbian you don't have
lesbian men
but you do have gay women yeah that's
very interesting I I I think
men care less women care more like
well across the board on everything I
feel like if yeah guys are more likely
to be like well women are way more
social creatures I don't know if you saw
there was this viral Tick Tock video
that was going on it was a trans man so
a biological female who essentially was
crying on Tick Tock saying let life was
so much harder living as a man than she
had thought it would be because it's
harder to make friends people aren't as
considerate and essentially like there
is no more feminine or only thing you
can do than be crying about these things
but I think it just Illustrated where
perhaps this isn't someone who is
secretly trapped inside a male body
because these are very feminine urges
that I you know not to say that men
can't have feelings or they don't but
overall like the the female experience
is just way more concerned with social
aspects being involved in a group and
all of that
like isolation yeah tends to be harder
on women for sure oh yeah for sure way
harder yeah men can be men can function
alone significantly better than women
can
not that they not that men constantly
you know not that every man doesn't mean
you know social interaction hashtag not
all averages Etc yeah but you know it's
much easier for for men to deal with
being alone I guess you can find that
like when you when you deal with like
like
um like Hermits and dudes that kind of
you know people that are off on their
own stuff it's very very very frequently
men it's very rarely in women and the
women give birth they're supposed to be
nurtured well not supposed to they tend
to be nurturing the baby and they're
they immediately they got that Bond
physical two people and the man is off
finding the food somewhere or something
right and I think what's really
interesting is that when we look at the
prevalence of autism diagnoses I'm not
even going to touch on how vaccines may
or may not relate to this I'm not trying
to get in trouble
um but we we see that I think a lot of
behaviors that may have just
traditionally been more male behaviors
because females overwhelmingly dominate
psychology I think they are essentially
trying to pathologize what a lot of time
is just regular male Behavior yes right
like not every man is autistic it's just
a man like sometimes they're just like
that I think as women we we want to say
that no you're wrong for thinking this
it's like no they're they're just
different than we are I think if we
really were in a patriarchy
human civilization would be a lot more
like Lion civilization you know where
the the males sleep all day wake up the
women bring them food and have the
babies and the men do very little but uh
that's not how it was yeah it was always
more so men running into burning
buildings working in sewers and
petroleum rigs I think holding up half
the world along with women I think if we
were actually a a patriarchy we'd be a
whole lot closer to Fascism than than to
liberalism I think we are in a fascist
system it's so peaceful very very much
not the government corporate collusion
like that's all like have you ever been
in some of these like Mom book club
they're very flashy bro I don't know let
me tell you about fascism okay
and this is not even an example of
fascism but I can tell you how far away
we are from it I was in Thailand and I
was hanging out at a restaurant with
some some individuals
and someone was explaining a story
about how some individuals had said f
the king
and then as soon as having said it went
because you are literally not allowed to
utter that sentence in any way for any
reason even if it is to criticize people
for having said it it's called Les
Majesty if you're in Thailand as a
tourist
and you say something like ah the King
is stupid you can be arrested and
charged for it if you know top of your
head can they have Queens Thailand or is
it male patriarchal only I don't know
expert on Thailand or anything all I can
tell you is I was there and there was an
issue of people having criticized the
royal family and got arrested and
charged for it and one of the
journalists who was down there was
explaining the story to me and having
repeated those words panicked and looked
around to make sure nobody saw them do
it because it was a crime yeah when you
take it very seriously growing up in
Asia I went to Thailand if you go to a
movie theater at least back then when I
was younger they will have a little
minute before the movie plays where you
have to stand and pay homage to the king
so they take it very seriously to be to
be fair King bhumipan was like based and
everyone really liked him oh yeah he did
like cool stuff helping the poor and
boosting literacy Queen Siri kit can't
can't speak for his son which people
have been very critical of but I'm not a
Thailand expert anything like that all I
know is that when I was there there were
people you asked the right I would ask
like someone from Thailand who was there
working with us and they'd be like yeah
the laws are really dumb but King really
is cool like he's not like a dictator or
anything like that but the law does kind
of put pressure on you in that way well
my point is simply this it's Thailand's
not even a fascist country you can fly
and you can do a lot of things but the
problem but that's authoritarianism
you're not even allowed to explain that
someone else criticized we're in like a
a Libertarian fascism system it's not
authoritarian but it is fascist in that
the government and the corporations have
become one almost even it's peaceful
that's on purpose public partnership but
even real Behavior even in fascist
countries like the you still had markets
like it wasn't like totally just the
government taking over so to call what
we have now like it's not fascist in in
in most of the the ways that people
conceptualize fat actually understand
fashion conceptualized fascism I get
that you're saying that there's you know
there's collusion between government and
and corporations I understand that but
like the the jingoism that comes along
with with fascism the militarism we're
not nearly as militaristic as people
like hyper traditionalism we have
nowhere near yeah not like that we are
not it's we are we are far closer to a
communist country than we are to a
fascist country really but yeah
absolutely I don't know man the
lucrative fascism and communism aren't
super different people act like people
love to talk about that they're they're
opposites their opposite sides of the
same coin the opposite is liberalism
Fascism and socialism are very similar
and in a communist state the
corporations the industry is yeah
communism is inherently fascist yes but
but they're not so so fascism is
traditionalist and communism is
Progressive the one of the the big
flights in Europe a large component of
it was the the the hard right factions
Nazis Fashions Etc were much more
traditionalist much more you know women
raising the family that kind of stuff
and the Communists were erase all
culture and start over you know I bet
there's something going on right here
with the word fascist because Mussolini
had the fascista was his political party
they were the fascists so there's the
big F fascist political party then
there's just the concept of fascism well
the word fascist basically just means
bad guy today so yeah which is
unfortunate because it specifically
means corporate government collusion I
mean you if you wanna if you want to
find out about fat or learn about
fascism read something from Giovanni
Gentile he's the guy that came up with
the idea of fascism
um and you'll unders you'll understand
that it's it's not just uh government
incorporation there's a lot of
nationalism there's oftentimes racism
included but not always like people
always think when you say fascist people
think Nazis and Nazi is Nazis were just
the the worst like manifestation of
fascism all not all fascists are Nazis
but all Nazis are fascists so it's like
right you know Mustangs and Fords not
all Fords are Mustangs but all Mustangs
are foreign one thing I sent you I gave
you a little post there right now I
think you should look up uh what if all
history because he just did a video
explaining liberalism communism and
fascism I think you'd learn uh this
amount about this video he's a great
dude his name is red yard check it out I
think you'll learn what if alt history
what about history all right we are
going to go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
because the members only show is coming
up and uh this one's gonna be spicy and
not family friendly as they often are
and this will pertain to issues of um
identity and law and government and
medications and stuff like that so
you'll uh you'll definitely check this
one out but uh we'll read some super
chats we have Goldilocks production says
Tim would you be willing to invite Tiki
history under the culture War to talk
about modern wokism as compared to Nazi
Germany and the difference between
Fascism and national socialism the
culture war is more so about having a
debate or dialectic on particular issues
I think I'll just let you guys know uh
tomorrow we have Destiny and John Doyle
and we'll be talking about masculinity
and
um just very briefly I asked Lauren if
she wanted to join as well because I am
such an embody you're a woman of
masculinity oh okay as a woman having
that perspective you know as like you
know two guys will be discussing
masculinity and family and stuff I think
having a female perspective would make
it a more robust conversation but I
don't want to Spring that on Destiny and
uh John Doyle so you know because they
were told like hey here's we're gonna do
it's gonna be you guys if they're cool
with it'll be awesome to have you so
that's tomorrow at 10 A.M at youtube.com
timcast as for the tiki history it's
just yes it's TK history he's also Ian
you should pick up Tak history another
great source yeah you know him I just
watched a video from the guy that you
mentioned I didn't know oh really yeah
but I just watched it like the other day
but uh as for this guy coming on the
culture War would be to this to discuss
conflicting ideas on an issue yeah I
don't think so on that show probably
doesn't make sense though no no this
show IRL you think you fit on here well
the challenge with IRL and the reason we
separated the shows is because this is
topical news which sometimes goes into
cultural issues that we care about and
so the issue with the culture war was if
we have someone like Lance or Matt
binder or you know Emma or whoever on
the show it turns into a two hour long
or like when vosh came out it was like a
five-hour debate like a five-hour
clashing on all these ideas and I'm just
like that's very different from what IRL
does where it's like we'll pull up a
story and then we'll talk about it and
we'll pop a story then we'll talk about
it we just did go into like a half an
hour conversation on a bunch of
different issues which is very cultural
but it's still if we're going to
intentionally invoke those discussions
and debates we should create a format
specifically for it I agree so really
really excited for tomorrow morning uh
to talk about these issues with uh
Destiny and John Doyle and then uh
assuming there's no issues lower and
joining as well would be absolutely
fantastic so that'll be super cool and
fun but uh we'll read some more Super
chats grafty says lightly gently push
the like button no damage that would be
great thank you very much
what do we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim you asked
last night about giving up on
Charlestown no way Jose once you get up
and running down there folks will move
in use can deaf find someone for the
city council Town takeover
so uh we are it's it's been a challenge
the first building we bought is
extremely difficult to deal with and uh
we're we're trying to get it sorted it's
just taking forever so a building uh
popped up for sale in Charlestown West
Virginia and uh we considered
buying that so that we have two
locations now so we can try and speed
things up
but I don't know man it's tough it's
tough I think do it go for it yeah
so I think I think Raymond is correct I
think a lot of people are correct
everyone said no you have to do it
because we have to take territory we
have to push back we can't let the
wokeness basically what happened was
Charleston passed a pride resolution
supporting pride month or something and
I'm like should we invest in a town
doing this everybody said yes because
then you'll create the inverse pressure
to push back on it agreed now the issue
is can we actually buy the building
because of is the building good to buy
right now it's like inspections and all
that stuff so it seems like we are
interested now and I agree thank you for
your input everyone I I think you are
correct in that now we actually have to
go through the motions of whether or not
we can actually buy the building outside
of the ideological reasons Raymond g
Stanley Jr batting a thousand bro I like
Charlestown too it's great it's
Jefferson County Jefferson County tends
to be pretty good so uh you know we'll
see or maybe we'll just do Harper's Fair
it's right next to harp oh man one of my
favorite cities dude Harper's fairy is
amazing I love it it's also Charles Town
not Charleston so yeah Charleston is
like five hours away and it's near
Kentucky yeah we're gonna mess up
yesterday very different
let's see what we got
Robert Knight says call this White House
appeal what it is attempting to legalize
fascism
fascism being the partnership of public
and private entities to further ideals
that was a component of it but fascism
like if you're looking at the bigger
picture was was was heavily like
traditionalist and like military
structures and it's I'm not going to
pretend to be an expert on fascism but
it's not not just that yeah that that
was a component that Mussolini had
pointed out but communism does the same
thing too Communists go in and take over
industry and then have government and
Industry collude and everything
effectively just take it over but you
get the point
here we go M says bring Joshua null moon
on the show he's interested who is that
I don't know if that is
you know we'll take a look
Kevin Brady says you cannot delete your
account referring to threads without
nuking your Instagram the data it Farms
is egregious as well it's a trap Banks
lifelog
well all right Joshua null moon is the
current owner of kiwi Farms I've heard
massive drama about that thing yeah no I
haven't been following that sounds like
a culture War show yeah
bringing on uh people to have big direct
discussions on a bunch of issues as
opposed to topical news
all right we'll read some more toaster
strudel says Tim you gotta have on two
people Pastor Mark Driscoll and Sean
folked is that you say it with let us
worship and hold the line both are
anti-wok and actively pushing back check
them out we definitely got to do our
culture war on religion with like Ian
and Sheamus and other people it's a good
sign there's a lot of potential guests
maybe we need more shows that cross more
shows uh maybe we do a culture War twice
a week that's a good idea yeah
there's also I mean if you're taking
suggestions for culture War there's a
very interesting thing happening uh I
guess among right-wing Christianity
where some are like hey muslims-based
allies or yeah Muslims enemies uh so
that's that's kind of I've been
interested in that conversation
happening Majid Nawaz I like a lot oh
he's great he's great and we there was
that famous video of um Muslims
protesting LGBT curriculums in schools
and leftist activists coming and
protesting back but saying we're doing
it for you we're doing it for you and
then there was that video recently where
the Muslim kids were stomping on the
pride flags and there was also that the
leaked audio of the Canadian teacher
telling this Muslim kid who was not
participating in Pride to get to the
fullest extent basically saying get out
of here go back to your country which is
not very liberal
um but yeah I I I'm very critical of
mass migration but I also studied Middle
East studies and I feel like I need to
like criticize my own side a lot of like
Evangelical Christians especially don't
really understand a lot of Islam so they
make a lot of uh just false statements
about Muslims so drail says Ian
Crossland is the goat what up Drell and
then he puts a goat Emoji in 100. dude
well everyone gets to serve that role at
least once Kyle Miller says do you think
threads is going to be installed by
default on our phones like Facebook yes
uh isn't it like you can't uninstall you
can't delete Facebook it just
deactivates well you can't like remove
it's going to be on your phone which is
annoying because I'm always running out
of memory and I don't go on Facebook on
my phone but I can't get rid of it well
if you have Android you can flash a new
you know operating system or something
that that that's not something super
easy to do you plug your phone into your
computer you download an app you clip go
you click go and it gives you a clean
operating system yeah Brandon no I don't
know like setting up a new phone is so
awful but my husband has been on this
quest to find a phone that does not rely
on Google like he he used to have the
voleophone which I don't think or uh
Linux was isn't there the Ubuntu phone
or something I don't know he's had he's
had problems he found a good one that
only worked in Canada and then we moved
he actually had to buy yet another phone
because it didn't work with American
carriers for some reason did you ever
look into the freedom phone yeah they
they sent us that to try but mine didn't
really work so I never endorsed it
interesting yeah we weren't able to
purchase them they were like out and
then we just kind of repeated off and my
girlfriend has one that she has to set
up as well we wanted to test them but we
didn't want to accept them from the
company because they you know it's a
potent phone or something but then we
tried to order and we couldn't get it so
we never did
all right Jason Hutchinson says what if
Lee Harvey was hired by the government
to be there under the guise of being
security and then they just used him as
an easy fall guy he said he won the
movie Shooter you guys can shoot her
with Mark Wahlberg yeah he's uh he's a
sniper retired they go to him and they
say we need your help someone's planning
an assassination and we need your your
expertise so he they bring him there and
say tell us where you think it's going
to happen and they bring him up in a
building and he goes there from over
there then he turns around and there's
some fat cop he's like what and the cop
shoots him yep he's the Fall Guy they
tried claiming with some crazy Reckless
living in the woods and that movie's
pretty good I like it
it was like I think it was kind of
obvious what they were going for with
that movie I think Oswald loaned his
rifle out to somebody like before all
that happened I could be this is
something I've heard uh I I defer to The
Experts which is what's his name the
director who did uh platoon
you know what I'm talking about
I don't know he's like the greatest
director of all time he was in Vietnam
he's on Rogan all right super chats I'll
come up with it yeah all right brown
bear says how long until they try and
claim the cocaine they found in the
White House is trumps wasn't there
already weren't there already people
posting it was Trump Juniors of course
they were like oh it was left over and
they found it yeah several years later
please director is Oliver Stone Oliver
Stone yeah JFK
we'll grab some more Super chats
what is this one Tyler kirbyson says
wouldn't it be funny if this was the
handlers of Biden can say the cocaine
was self-doping and not propping up the
stooge sleepy Joe clearly they have been
given the go-ahead to trash Biden yeah I
think they're they're just trying to
find a way to get Biden out and
they're going to give them like a
moderate fall nothing too crazy but it's
gonna be like oh I can't do this anymore
or something bad happens to Hunter and
he's like oh you know
you mean like a literal fall no I mean
like a political fault oh yeah no not a
literal one he's had many of those did
you guys see if camel is now the lowest
rated BP in American history which is
Dick Cheney shot a guy
so that's pretty bad that's based yeah I
forgot about that jeez was that like a
from a poll yeah yeah how many do you
know how many people were pulled no I'm
not sure but I mean anecdotally I don't
have problems believing it but I'm not
sure like what the margins were or
anything like that or the sample size BH
Godsmack says if I let chat GPT write a
book for me am I now an author and
writer yes so let me break this down
because we've talked about this
we're heading towards a future where
you'll be able to open up an app and
type in
make a movie about a man with uh the
power of ice who saves the world from an
evil dragon that is trying to uh blow up
the earth oh it will then render that
thing for you however it will not be
rendered perfectly the story could be
slightly boring so what you do is and
you can do this now
you can go to the open AI playground and
say write me a story about uh hippie
named Ian who discovers a graphene alloy
which Saves the World it will then write
a story
you'll read the first few sentences ago
that's pretty good oh this sentence is
stupid you'll erase half of it and then
correct it might say
once Ian discovered the graphene he sold
it for one million dollars you stop
erase one million input one billion
dollars then click go and it will start
writing again with your prompt my point
is you can have it write stories for you
where periodically you have to correct
the path it's on to make it work
properly I suppose in the future AI will
just make really great stories because
it'll get better and better at it but I
kind of do feel like you will always
need some human element to make it more
acceptable to humans so it's not just
about telling you to write a book it's
about going in and creating the paths
that the writing goes in fact that would
be the human censoring the AI and you do
need a sensor well if it's not offensive
our question was does AI produce R not
does that make the person the artist so
that's a different thing he's
yeah I think I think it still does but
even then like I I there are people who
think that art is the process and there
are people who think that art is the
result I'm someone who thinks more that
our art is the result I am I'm
comfortable saying that you know AI
creates this beautiful Masterpiece
that's art some uh Nuvo like avant-garde
like shoe on a floor
Modern Art that's not art I'm
comfortable saying that but I think some
people who are saying like no it's all
about The Human Experience then you lead
yourself to a position where an amazing
Masterpiece by AR is not art but the the
shoe on the floor is art grizzlab says I
make AI generated realistic images of
women and sell not safer work content
online now I'm making over 1 000 per
month in subscription for men who SIM
for AI images of realistic women that is
incredible if that's true that is
incredible stuff is just so terrible
there are now ai girlfriends like AI
girlfriend chat box if you guys use AI
to produce images or stories or anything
put it in the description of the art
yeah we're ethics we're legit very very
close to Robo girlfriends I just saw
this movie recent drama episode about
that I saw this movie recently and it
was called um
what was it called what was it no no no
no it's about a husband and wife they
get their their robot servants everybody
has they make copies of each other and
download their memories in the event one
one or the other dies
so you guys are listening May note movie
this is and then the guy dies and so she
activates the robot but then thinks it's
a mistake and tries to kick him out and
then it's it's got the guy from uh Shang
chi in it
and uh do you guys know what this movie
is called I'm looking in the chat
somebody knows
what was the name of that movie I just
watched it you meant surrogates and I
thought like ex machina but like I don't
I don't know what that is
uh nobody seems to know what the movie
is so uh it's not surrogates it's about
shaqbots it's about uh these AI are
becoming sentient and the company has AI
police who go and try and stop them from
going rogue and then this guy has all
the memories of the dude he was based on
he wants he wants to keep that life
and it's not altered carbon nobody knows
this movie series Detroit but not
serious surrogates is about people who
pilot robots how does nobody know the
name of this movie is it simulator is it
what yes he's in it okay so go to go
yeah go to his filmography
because I think this movie just came out
recently I watched some Black Mirror the
other night that was nuts I'll tell I
got his Wikipedia right here I'm gonna
pull up his filmography I'll tell you
what this movie was Cool Runnings
oh is this from a while ago upload wait
are these oh that's television
Bicentennial it was uh simulant simulant
simulant interestingness are so funny
yeah simulant is the name of the movie I
thought it was uh decently good
yeah cool yeah but I think so so you
know he dies and the wife is like I want
my husband back so she turns this robot
on and then she's like this is insane
and creepy I don't want to do this
anymore but then you know she like I
would have to destroy him then the
aerobics like I want an AI girlfriend
where this is gonna happen people like
every every incel will have a waifu you
better hope my wife who doesn't want a
robot and gets sick of a human because
the human's not going to be able to keep
up I want to find someone who can direct
short films because I want to do a bunch
of these short films right how about a
10 minute short film where some incel
buys a waifu and then she's like a
perfect wife but then the beings like
the robots are becoming sentient and
then are like I don't want this life
like you know there have been similar
things like that right become human you
should play that game I did it was okay
but like yes there's stories like it you
know where
robots become sentient you know I would
be fun to make these uh I think we have
40 of the crew we've got the writer and
the director now we just need like two
three more people including one female
actor we need someone who can like take
the idea write the script knows how to
execute the script and I want to have an
AI write a script and do exactly what
you're saying where they the writer like
Wesley or something goes in and changes
some of it just it'll be like written by
Wesley Roth and artificial intelligence
they've done that and they're not neces
like some of them are not necessarily
worse than what Bollywood pumps up
nowadays not to say that it's good but
some some stuff that actually gets made
nowadays is pretty bad but regarding
like the AI girlfriend it's gonna really
really change male female Dynamics
because with an AI girlfriend these chat
Bots we're already seeing it like
ultimately the chatbot is inclined to
keep you paying so it's not an I mean I
guess you could say well so is the
actual woman because we want your
resources and so it's all about the
money robots
um but I think I think would be it would
really really change what humans expect
from relationship relationships if we're
basing them off of machines you know
what's going to happen every every
person will have a robo partner and then
what will happen is when they want to
have kids they'll submit their info to
the clinic
then people will go to the clinic go
through the clinic database and then be
like who would you like to have a
partner with and you'll swipe like
Tinder you'll never actually meet the
person but eventually someone will swipe
right on you and then it'll be like this
person has matched with you press ok to
you know create child I wonder surrogacy
industry is booming we're already
getting closer to that it will not
eventually happen like that same thing
that happens with Tinder will happen on
that it'll be a small portion of people
are the ones that people like I want to
have yeah yeah oh I didn't say that
wasn't gonna happen oh I thought I
thought you said So eventually and they
were and there will but you know
if like
women on Tinder typically go for the top
20 of guys but the bottom percentage of
guys still sometimes do get matches so
you will still see pair like this kind
of thing happening and then what will
happen is the clinic will grow the baby
in a pod yeah and then you will have
your joint custody with your robot it
will be delivered to you oh my god this
is already happening and it'll be like a
dinosaur costume
it's already happening to some extent
with surrogacy I'm wondering if they're
going to have the guy do his thing into
a cup in his house that's connected to a
computer that can retro it could that it
can measure the chemicals in the semen
and then no reverse engineer it on the
other end and inseminate the woman
without ever having to actually go mail
it DNA maybe in the future DNA analysis
but what I imagine will happen is the
guy will engage in relations with his
Robo wife who will then be alive go back
to the headquarters like I'm gonna go
back to the clinic and it's going to be
totally like that was really fun honey
I'm gonna go to the clinic and deliver
your C need for your child and he'll be
like great and then she'll get in the
car and she'll drive or you know Wheels
come out of her legs like you know that
robot from The Jetsons or whatever
Rosie there you go Viking vet says your
argument about check the IDS means we
get rid of online anonymity so are you
against online anonymity the only way to
get keep your arguing for opening the
gate to never having your personal
information kept private talk about the
straw man to end off straw man arguments
are you against in person anonymity I
guess would be me saying children should
not be allowed to watch porn and then
going you're against anonymity okay nice
straw man attempt it makes me think you
probably want to give kids porn there's
a difference I could see it opening a
gate to being like now you need an ID to
sign up for Twitter if you're going to
use social media you need an ID and then
it's like how about I think so Twitter
is public you are not allowed to post
illegal content some things are illegal
we like free speech does not mean you
can go out and have sex in public
because that's not what free speech is
and when it comes to burning Flags
you can't the left likes to argue you're
the Supreme Court world we can burn our
flags dude yes but you can't set fire to
objects in public if you have a
controlled space and you own the flag
you can burn it you can't start fires in
the middle of the street that's called
arson
well I don't know that that would
specifically be arson but probably
something in line with that so you can
go online you could be anonymous but if
someone wants to deliver Contraband like
some some controlled content or
substance or whatever yeah you can't
anonymously buy booze I don't know I
don't know man this it does feel like
you can do it illegal Trojan Horse if
they're like no we're doing it for your
own good we're doing it to protect you
yeah see I've never like
people want poor and more than they want
to protect children from point
and that's it's the crazy thing to me
that people are like I've never been
that's why I've never been a hardcore
staunch libertarian like the guy who got
up on stage of libertarian party and
argued about selling heroin kids I'm
like nope
yeah like sorry I don't go over that
level of degradation like and and
degeneracy
we have to have reasonable limits where
we agree we want to stop people from
harming children there has got to be
some moral standard that's just that's
right
yeah yeah we would always talk about
should we have porn on the system and it
was like bill was like I want
full open trans like he was like he's
the transparency guy he's he loves it
and then John is like the more
conservative he's like no no no no we're
not turning into a porn site and it was
like just a kind of an ongoing
conversation about what do we do because
it's an anonymous you don't need a a
personality like you don't need to give
data to sign up you just need an email
address Viking vet says your position on
online information is anti-freedom
freedom is dangerous and takes constant
vigilance there needs to be better
restrictions for child accounts not
restrict anonymity no social media till
18. I just love this fake argument
you've made up about me opposing
anonymity but then you literally made an
argument for Banning kids from social
media till 18 which would require
identification no we just asked them and
they'll tell the truth yeah people
wouldn't lie on the internet too right
so I'm actually not arguing against
anonymity
I'm saying you can't post porn in public
if you want to make it so that kids
can't use social media tell 18 that
would require everyone to send their ID
to the social media company to prove
their age I'm not arguing that you sir
are opposed to anonymity
let's grab some more Super chats as we
move on
what do we got
it's a good Super Chat night by the way
taga says Ian's logic is the same logic
left his teachers using schools to teach
LGBT plus kink in elementary and middle
schools well it's on Tick Tock so we
might as well teach it because it's in
the world it's not just that they've
quite literally said this it is one of
their principal arguments children are
being exposed to this stuff they're
seeing it and if we don't teach them
they'll be confused and my response is
why are kids seeing things that were not
legal to to publish in the first place
when did we start allowing all of these
laws to be broken with no enforcement
this is why I'm kind of like you know
this country is fractured and falling
apart the United States Civil War it's
not just about the fact that people are
screaming each other and Joe Biden's
locking up innocent or locking up people
without charge or trial I say innocent
because there's no charges until proven
guilty but to lock someone up without
charge or trial for two years and and
you know torture them yeah this country
has just Fallen apart but the idea that
the our law enforcement apparatus has
allowed antifa Riders to just do
whatever they want has you know all this
violence and vandalism crime is
skyrocketing child uh kids going to
adult sex shows in Texas and the cops
being like Oh I'm not going to do
anything about it people posting lewton
lascivious content on the internet which
is already illegal and the cops doing
nothing about it even in West Virginia
yeah there's no law enforcement it's an
arco-tierney absolutely yeah it's really
up to the parents to enforce their
child's mind I I think you just can't
rely on the state to do that and I don't
encourage what does that mean the
parents got to say no you're not going
on the internet you can't just be like
hey it's not just at in the internet as
Tim is pointed out this is also
something getting in public schools so
we're just failing on all fronts to keep
this away from kids and this argument
that you can't rely on law enforcement
for this reason is is illogical we rely
on law enforcement to enforce tons of
laws not just looting actions in public
but I think that the powers of B will
make a law to to then enforce the
whatever they want and you really need
to have a parent to enforce morality
which the government's not always going
to be the moral force of good correct we
we do need a moral Society because when
you don't have one the police stop
enforcing the laws when children are
brought to sex shows where things are
written on the wall saying it's not
going to lick itself and when people
start complaining that children are
being exposed to adult sex shows the
cops go well don't look at me I can't do
anything about it when they actually
could because it's illegal the cops
don't enforce the laws anymore that's
what happens when you have no moral
Society yeah they're afraid against sued
and stuff like that it's not good but
just to speak back to this this last
Super Chat I don't uh Advocate to show
kids the horrible things that I'm trying
to prevent them from seeing I used to
think think like well if it's out there
then I should expose myself to it but
after I saw enough people's arms get
blown off I was like I think it's
changing me I don't want to see it
anymore
um if you're an adult but you need this
you need to protect you need to prepare
children if you're going to send them
out there into the internet you need to
prepare them somehow well I think we can
prepare children by saying this is how
you safely go online you don't click the
links like there's going to be people
who are trying to talk to you like don't
don't do that that's one thing allowing
them to navigate safely online in
addition to parental controls but I
think the way that the left view it it's
like it's not just that we need to teach
them to navigate safely online we need
to teach them about all these terrible
things before other people can introduce
it to them I got an interview we're
almost out of time I want to read two
more messages one's from frog club and
the regular chat he says for ffs Tim for
fsig you can't rely on law enforcement
Tim people loot can loot shops and you
talk about it yourself yes my point is
this
police are not enforcing the law and
they should be I am not saying that we
should just accept the way things are
and then expect them to be different I'm
saying they should literally be
different and we should actually affect
change
to have the pleasure my point is this I
agree cops aren't enforcing the law we
have an immoral amoral society and cops
are refusing to do their jobs so no you
can't rely on law enforcement we need to
change culture so that law enforcement
begin to do their job once again we have
to change it for that in that way I'm
not an anarchist I am not someone who is
like there should be no cops ever my
point you know in the in the uh simple
version with what we have going on in
major cities is if cops are not enforced
in the law we shouldn't have cops at all
so defund them and abolish them
in reality what we do want is a moral
Society where cops are moral respect the
constitutional rights of individuals
strive to bring about True Justice and
it's very very difficult to maintain and
lastly Josh
playly says hey Tim have you started
setup uh started slash set up your
business grant program for cultural
positive program who should I reach out
to to throw my head in
technically we have done a couple
already it is we've got to figure out
how we're doing it because it's kind of
just vague and nebulous I've given some
people money to keep up their work
um ideally we have a forum in the
members only chat where people can post
the things that they're they're working
on and then we do shout outs on Friday
for uh different stuff that uh uh our
members have worked on to to help
promote their their products so become a
member at timcast.com that being said
we're gonna go to the members show now
things look a little spicy not so family
friendly so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends go to
timcast.com click join us and then in a
few minutes we will have that live
uncensored show where U.S members can
submit questions and even call into the
show so definitely check that out uh you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally at timcast
Lauren do you want to shout anything out
um I guess if you want to follow me on
my YouTube channel Lauren Chen for
political social stuff yeah sorry I'm
like very poppy on our mic so I'm like
scared to get close uh so yeah Lauren
Chen YouTube channel political social
stuff a mediaholic for the pop culture
entertainment stuff and I am at the
Lauren Chen on Twitter Instagram
telegram basically everywhere uh you can
also find my videos on TP USA there's
socials and YouTube account as well as
Blaze TV
I am uh Phil that remains on Twitter uh
Philip remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains we're available
you can find us on Spotify on Pandora
Apple music YouTube the whole night and
I mean Crossland uh you guys should
check out cast Castle on timcast.com if
you haven't seen it yet there have been
some really good episodes the last four
weeks Chris Bertman this guy's awesome
if you don't know him you'll love them
it's great yeah he's a great actor Chris
you knocked me off my socks man I love
you good work I'm looking forward to
working with you more man Wesley great
job Aaron nice work
yeah uh Chris Bertman is definitely
definitely something isn't he uh I'm
serge.com
um follow me on the internet I'm all
over the place I'm using threads too but
I think it's not long for this world see
you guys around we will see you all over
at timcast.com in a few minutes thanks
for hanging up